With Instacart, you get groceries that over-deliver. And with Instacart's in-store prices at select stores, you can do more this winter without paying more. So double down on your shortbread production without upping the price. Add more chilies to your chili without the added sting. Go completely ham on candy DMs and celebrate the season of being extra without paying extra. So download the app today and get $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Instacart. Groceries that over-deliver.
使用 Instacart，您可以获得超值的杂货。而且在部分商店，Instacart 提供店内价格，让您在这个冬天花更少的钱，做更多的事。所以，在不增加成本的情况下，尽情增加您的黄油饼干产量吧。在不增加负担的情况下，在您的辣椒里多加点辣椒。尽情享受糖果的甜蜜，庆祝这个季节，无需多花钱，就能享受加倍的快乐。立即下载应用程序，前三单免运费。Instacart。超值的杂货。
Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Welcome to our second drink of Money Part 1. Oh, I loved this episode. Angela, I remember we reached out to Paul Lieberstein about this one. He wrote and directed it. He had such good stuff to share. So many good details. Well, look, I want to kick off the second drink with a deleted Michael talking head.
服务费、除外条款和条款适用。欢迎来到我们《金钱（上）》的第二杯饮品。哦，我太喜欢这一集了。安吉拉，我记得我们联系了保罗·利伯斯坦谈这一集。他负责编剧和导演。他分享了很多精彩的内容。有很多很棒的细节。好吧，听着，我想用一个迈克尔的删减版谈话头（talking head）来开启这第二杯饮品。
We did not discuss this in our first rewatch. Oh. Let me set it up for you. Okay. So remember how Jan is bringing in fabrics for Michael. to look at. Yes, she's spending like all his money on redecorating. The condo, yes. Okay. Well, Michael has a talking head. It's in the kitchen. He's alone. And he shares that he has a friend who actually loves interior design. And I thought you should hear who he's talking about.
我们在第一次重温时没有讨论过这个。哦。让我为你铺垫一下。好的。还记得简（Jan）给迈克尔带布料来看吗？是的，她几乎花光了他所有的钱来重新装修。公寓，没错。好吧，迈克尔有一个谈话头。在厨房里。他一个人。他分享说他有一个非常热爱室内设计的朋友。我觉得你应该听听他说的是谁。
You know who loves interior design? My friend, Todd Packer, he, uh, he is always asking if Jan's carpet matches or drapes. He, now, although he says that he prefers it when there is no carpet, which doesn't make sense because I've been to his apartment and there is shag carpeting all over the place. So I guess people's design sensibilities change. Okay. They needed to cut this.
你知道谁热爱室内设计吗？我的朋友托德·帕克（Todd Packer），他，呃，他总是问简的地毯和窗帘是否搭配。他，虽然他说他更喜欢没有地毯的时候，但这说不通，因为我去过他的公寓，到处都是长毛地毯。所以我猜人们的审美观是会变的。好吧。他们需要剪掉这一段。
Can I tell you why? Yeah. Because in the pilot, isn't it the pilot? Todd Packer calls and says, ask her if the carpet matches the draughts. And Michael's like, Like Michael clear on it. He knows what that phrase means.
我能告诉你为什么吗？嗯。因为在试播集中，是试播集吧？托德·帕克打电话来说，问她地毯和窗帘是否搭配。迈克尔就像是，迈克尔很清楚。他知道那个短语是什么意思。
But in this talking head, he has no clue. No, he's clueless. No clue. I mean, Todd Packer has shag carpeting. Well, that's an insight. Yeah, it is. Kind of perfect, though, also. For sure.
但在这一段谈话头里，他完全没头绪。不，他一无所知。完全没头绪。我是说，托德·帕克有长毛地毯。嗯，这真是一个洞察。是的，确实。不过，也挺完美的。肯定的。
He probably also has a waterbed or a like a round bed. He has a waterbed, yes. He definitely has a mirror on the ceiling, too. Oh. Well, moving on, I have a question from Ruth Ann C about this episode. She says, every time I watch this episode, it strikes me how surprised Pam is to see the outhouse at Shrewt Farms. But haven't they been there for hours at that point? Wouldn't Pam have had to go to the bathroom before then?
他可能还有水床或者圆床。他确实有水床，没错。他天花板上肯定还有镜子。哦。好吧，继续，我有一个来自露丝·安·C（Ruth Ann C）关于这一集的问题。她说，每次我看这一集，我都觉得帕姆（Pam）看到舒特农场（Schrute Farms）的茅房时表现得那么惊讶，这让我印象深刻。但那时他们不是已经在那里待了几个小时了吗？难道帕姆在那之前不需要上厕所吗？
I feel like that's a long time to not go pee. Anyone else, Jenna, Angela. Agree. You agree? I mean, I feel like getting to Shrewt Farms is probably a little bit of a drive, right? It's not like in Scranton. It's on the outskirts. And by the time I got there, the first thing I'd have to do is go pee.
我觉得那么久不上厕所太难了。还有别人吗，珍娜（Jenna），安吉拉。同意。你同意吗？我是说，我觉得去舒特农场可能要开一段路，对吧？不像在斯克兰顿（Scranton）市区。它在郊区。等我到那里的时候，我第一件事肯定就是去上厕所。
when I arrived. Well, let me say that when we introduce the idea of shrewd farms, it is in season two. You know, that's the one where Michael buys his condo and Dwight talks about owning shrewd farms. And he says, there's only one bathroom and it's under the porch. That's what he says. So I'm wondering if Pam knows this information about the lack of bathrooms, maybe she made Jim stop before they got to shrewp farms. somewhere. Maybe she peed in a field. I don't know. Okay. Okay. So I think maybe she hasn't needed a bathroom for hours. Well, I'm with Ruth Ann. I'm wondering what's up. Well, also in this breakdown,
当我到达的时候。好吧，让我说，当我们引入舒特农场的概念时，是在第二季。你知道，那是迈克尔买公寓，德怀特（Dwight）谈论拥有舒特农场的那一集。他说，只有一个厕所，而且在门廊下面。他就是这么说的。所以我怀疑帕姆是否知道厕所不足的信息，也许她让吉姆（Jim）在到达舒特农场之前停过车。在某个地方。也许她在田野里解决了。我不知道。好吧。好吧。所以我认为也许她几个小时都不需要上厕所。好吧，我和露丝·安有同感。我想知道是怎么回事。好吧，同样在这个解析中，
we discuss how cute Pam's outfit is that she's sleeping in. And we started discussing the various things people can sleep in. And I asked, does anybody actually sleep in like a silky slip nightgown like you see in the movies all the time? Yeah. If I remember, you sort of put out a call to action. Like, tell me, if you do this, will you tell me? We got a fan meal flirty. Jana, Kristen, Becca, Christina, and many more said that they do sleep in silk nighties. In fact, Becca said, I do have nightgowns in my sleepwear rotation. They are mostly designated for summertime. They are soft and comfortable. And a few other folks said that they're cooler to sleep in, and that's why they like them. Well, if they're cooler to sleep in, we might should start
我们讨论了帕姆睡觉时穿的衣服有多可爱。我们开始讨论人们睡觉时穿的各种衣服。我问，真的有人像电影里那样穿着丝绸吊带睡裙睡觉吗？是的。如果我没记错的话，你发起了一个行动号召。比如，告诉我，如果你这样做，你会告诉我吗？我们收到了粉丝邮件狂潮。珍娜、克里斯汀、贝卡、克里斯蒂娜等等很多人说她们确实穿丝绸睡裙睡觉。事实上，贝卡说，我的睡衣轮换里确实有睡裙。它们主要是为夏天准备的。它们柔软舒适。还有几个人说它们穿起来更凉快，这就是她们喜欢的原因。好吧，如果它们穿起来更凉快，我们也许应该开始
trying it. I mean, as women of a certain age with certain kind of hot slashes at night, it might be silk 90 time. Okay, our second fan mail flurry was about the poster in Dwight's room. So if you remember, it's a very super quick cutaway, and I became obsessed with it. I zoomed in on it, you know, like I took a picture of the screen, right? And I had a theory, because it's a little blurry. Okay. I thought, ooh, this is a little foreshadowing nugget. It's got to, to be Motley Crew, right? Yes, I remember. Dwight loves Motley crew. But, lady, many people wrote in to tell me. Very nicely, by the way, Michelle, Stephen, Emily, Morgan, Nate, Tara, Molly, and Moore said, Angela, it is a Van Halen poster. Oh. Tara, I want to thank you because you
尝试一下。我是说，作为一定年纪的女性，晚上有某种潮热，也许是时候穿丝绸睡裙了。好的，我们的第二个粉丝邮件狂潮是关于德怀特房间里的海报。如果你还记得，那是一个非常快的切镜头，我对此着迷了。我放大了它，你知道，就像我拍了屏幕的照片，对吧？我有一个理论，因为它有点模糊。好的。我想，噢，这是一个小小的伏笔。一定是莫特利克鲁乐队（Motley Crue），对吧？是的，我记得。德怀特喜欢莫特利克鲁。但是，女士，很多人写信告诉我。顺便说一句，非常客气，米歇尔、斯蒂芬、艾米丽、摩根、内特、塔拉、莫莉等等都说，安吉拉，那是范·海伦（Van Halen）的海报。哦。塔拉，我想谢谢你，因为你
did write. But you know what, Angela, it was a nice theory. So thank you for that. Listen, these are in the same world. Motley Crew, Van Halen. They're adjacent. They're adjacent. You were on the right track. Mm-hmm. Well, we also got a great background catch by Danny. Danny pointed out that the sofa that Jim and Pam are sitting on when they arrived at Shrewt Farms, it has a very nice nod to Scranton. There is a Scranton PA throw blanket. It's stitched across the front. It says Scranton, go to nine minutes, 12 seconds. It's draped over the back of the sofa and get this. What? Ben L. from Pittsburgh doubled down on this catch and said the same blanket comes back in where. women's appreciation when the fellows go hang out in the ladies' bathroom. We had clearly one Scranton, Pennsylvania blanket. Mm-hmm. Well, I love that they just kept repurposing it. Those are great catches.
确实写信了。但你知道吗，安吉拉，那是个不错的理论。所以谢谢你。听着，它们在同一个世界里。莫特利克鲁，范·海伦。它们是邻近的。它们是邻近的。你的方向是对的。嗯哼。好吧，我们还收到了丹尼（Danny）的一个很棒的背景发现。丹尼指出，吉姆和帕姆到达舒特农场时坐的沙发，对斯克兰顿有一个非常好的致敬。有一条斯克兰顿宾夕法尼亚州的毯子。它缝在前面。上面写着斯克兰顿，去到9分12秒。它披在沙发背上，还有这个。什么？来自匹兹堡的本·L（Ben L.）证实了这个发现，并说同样的毯子出现在哪里。在《女性欣赏》（Women's Appreciation）那一集中，当男士们去女士洗手间闲逛时。我们显然只有一条斯克兰顿，宾夕法尼亚州的毯子。嗯哼。好吧，我喜欢他们一直重复使用它。这些都是很棒的发现。
Very good. I mean, the same blanket at Shrewp Farms and the women's restroom. Wow, that's attention to detail. Well, lastly, I went into our candy bag alts for this episode, and there were so many fun Michael talking heads. I thought I'd share two alts, okay? Remember when Michael shares that he and Jan are down to only. one car. And, you know, they did this to save money. But then, of course, Jan wanted a Porsche.
非常好。我是说，同样的毯子出现在舒特农场和女洗手间。哇，这真是注重细节。好吧，最后，我看了这一集的糖果袋备选片段，有很多有趣的迈克尔谈话头。我想分享两个备选，好吗？还记得迈克尔分享说他和简现在只有一辆车了吗？而且，你知道，他们这样做是为了省钱。但后来，当然，简想要一辆保时捷。
So she's driving a Porsche, but they only have one car. Well, there were two alts for this talking head and they cracked me up. Jan and I are sharing a car now. I love the seepering. But, you know, the ozone layers are peeling. The ice hats are melting. And no owls have been spotted in a long time. And the other birds. Oh. Lady. What? The ice hats are melting. Oh, it's a mangled. Michael mangled word. It's ice caps. Okay. The next one is, Jan and I are sharing a car now.
所以她在开保时捷，但他们只有一辆车。好吧，这个谈话头有两个备选，它们让我笑喷了。简和我现在共用一辆车。我喜欢这辆赛百灵（Sebring）。但是，你知道，臭氧层正在剥落。冰帽正在融化。而且很久没有看到猫头鹰了。还有其他鸟类。哦。女士。什么？冰帽正在融化。哦，这是一个被毁掉的词。迈克尔毁掉了一个词。是冰盖（ice caps）。好的。下一个是，简和我现在共用一辆车。
The lease got up on the Sebring and we could have gotten two so-so cars or one really nice car. Our three really crappy cars are zero really, really great ones or a fleet of mopeds. But Jan shot that down. Oh, okay. This is how he money manages. Yes. He's going to trade in the Sebring and get a fleet of mopeds. Or three crappy cars.
赛百灵的租约到期了，我们本可以买两辆马马虎虎的车，或者一辆非常好的车。我们的三辆破车，或者零辆非常非常好的车，或者一队轻便摩托车。但简否决了那个提议。哦，好吧。这就是他的理财方式。是的。他打算卖掉赛百灵，买一队轻便摩托车。或者三辆破车。
Yeah. All right. Well, I hope you enjoyed our little extra tidbits. And now here is our second drink of money part one. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi, everybody. Hey there. You guys, I'm so excited to be here today.
是的。好吧。好吧，我希望你喜欢我们这些额外的小花絮。现在是我们的《金钱（上）》第二杯饮品。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）。我是安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士（Office Ladies）。大家好。嘿。伙计们，我今天很高兴能来到这里。
Not that I'm not always excited, but I don't know. I just really enjoyed this episode. It cracked me up. I liked it too. I, it was a surprise to me. I had kind of a little bit forgotten about this one. Yeah, I hadn't seen this in a good while. So it was just fun to be an audience.
并不是说我一直不兴奋，但我不知道。我只是真的很喜欢这一集。它让我笑个不停。我也喜欢。这对我来说是个惊喜。我有点忘记这一集了。是的，我很久没看了。所以作为观众感觉很有趣。
Well, let's tell everyone what we're talking about today. it is Money Part 1, which is Season 4, Episode 7, written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Paul Lieberstein. Yes. Should I hit you with a summary? I was hoping you would. I knew you were. I knew you wouldn't let it go by without a summary.
好吧，让我们告诉大家我们今天在谈论什么。是《金钱（上）》，也就是第四季第七集，由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，保罗·利伯斯坦导演。是的。我应该给你一个总结吗？我正希望你这么做。我知道你会的。我知道你不会让它没有总结就过去。
A great summary? I would never. An amazing summary by me? I'm hoping for a summary and three fast facts. I mean, come on. Oh, lady, you're going to be happy. Good. I'm going to sip my tea and listen and only judge a little.
一个很棒的总结？我绝不会。一个由我带来的精彩总结？我期待着一个总结和三个快速事实。我是说，拜托。哦，女士，你会开心的。好的。我要喝口茶，听着，只评判一点点。
Go for it. What? All right, here we go. Here's a summary. Michael is forced to confront his money woes as Jan renovates his condo. He has to take a second job as a telemarketer. Pam and Jim spend a night at Dwight's family beet farm, which he is now running as a bed and breakfast. Kelly and Daryl work on their relationship, and Andy tries to woo Angela.
开始吧。什么？好吧，我们开始吧。这是一个总结。迈克尔被迫面对他的金钱困境，因为简正在装修他的公寓。他不得不找一份电话推销员的兼职。帕姆和吉姆在德怀特的家庭甜菜农场度过了一晚，他现在把那里经营成了一家民宿。凯莉（Kelly）和达里尔（Daryl）在处理他们的关系，安迪（Andy）试图追求安吉拉。
Thank you. Any judgments? Any judgments there? No. No. No. Oh. Not yet. Good so far. All right. Well, fast fact number one. Now I mentioned that this episode was written by Paul and directed by Paul. But this was actually the first episode directed by Paul Lieberstein. Ah. Yeah. So he will go on to direct many more, but this was his office directorial debut. Oh, gee. Yeah. So I reached out to him because I was like, I mean, he wrote it. He directed it. Let's hear from him. Yeah. And he told me that he wrote this episode while he was on vacation in Russia. What? Yeah. I didn't know he'd ever vacation in Russia. Paul would have been a really interesting thing to banter about while we were on set waiting for lights to go up and stuff. He's holding back. I did know he'd been to Russia. Oh. There you go. How was it? Was it great? It was great. He had a great, great time. Well, he said that he was so excited to be able to write and direct this episode because it featured the first visit to Dwight's farmhouse at Shrewt Farms.
谢谢。有什么评判吗？有什么评判吗？没有。没有。没有。哦。还没呢。目前为止很好。好吧，好吧，快速事实一。现在我提到这一集是由保罗编剧和导演的。但这实际上是保罗·利伯斯坦导演的第一集。啊。是的。所以他以后会导演更多，但这确实是他在《办公室》的导演处女作。哦，天哪。是的。所以我联系了他，因为我想，我是说，他写了它。他导演了它。让我们听听他的说法。是的。他告诉我，他在俄罗斯度假时写了这一集。什么？是的。我不知道他曾经在俄罗斯度假。保罗，这本来是一个非常有趣的话题，可以在我们片场等待灯光亮起时闲聊。他藏着掖着。我确实知道他去过俄罗斯。哦。就是这样。怎么样？很棒吗？很棒。他玩得非常非常开心。好吧，他说他非常兴奋能编写和导演这一集，因为它包含了第一次访问德怀特在舒特农场的农舍。
Because we've been there. We saw the barn in the initiation and all that. But he got to completely invent Dwight's home and what it looked like and all of that stuff. and he said that he got the idea for Dwight to run a bed and breakfast during a trip to Italy a couple years before. He is a world traveler. He's well traveled. Yes. So while he was in Italy, he had seen a bunch of signs for this farm B&B stay. You go stay on people's farms in Italy. Sounds amazing. I just want Paul to know if you're listening, Paul, you don't have to go all the way to Italy for that. You can have a farm B&B right here. I'm sure like my family farm in Texas would take you in. I would love to have a farm B&B experience at your parents' farm. I would love that so much. I would love to get up in the morning and go check on the cows with you. Oh,
因为我们去过那里。我们在《入会仪式》（Initiation）中看到了谷仓等等。但他可以完全创造德怀特的家，它看起来是什么样子的，以及所有这些东西。他说，他在几年前去意大利旅行时想到了让德怀特经营民宿的想法。他是一个世界旅行者。他去过很多地方。是的。所以当他在意大利时，他看到了很多农场民宿住宿的标志。你去意大利的农场住。听起来太棒了。我只是想让保罗知道，如果你在听，保罗，你不必大老远跑到意大利去。你可以在这里拥有一个农场民宿。我相信像我在德克萨斯州的家庭农场会欢迎你的。我很乐意在你父母的农场体验农场民宿。我会非常喜欢的。我很乐意早上起床，和你一起去看看牛。哦，
lady, you're speaking my language. Well, Paul just said he loved imagining Dwight as a proprietor of a bed-and-break and he also told me he did so much to prepare for this episode. He really like over-prepared because it was just a really big deal to him and he wanted it to be full of so many details. And it was. Oh, yes. There's so many cool details and we're going to point them out to you as they come up. Definitely. All right, fast fact number two is a location breakdown. I knew this was coming. The Shrut Farm's location breakdown. I have been to this farm many times. Let's hear what you got. So we mentioned before that we shot shrewd farms on the Disney ranch in Santa Clarita, California. We went back for this episode, and this time we used the Olivia's house
女士，你说到我心坎里了。好吧，保罗只是说他喜欢想象德怀特作为民宿老板的样子，他还告诉我他为这一集做了很多准备。他真的像是过度准备了，因为这对他来说是一件大事，他希望它充满很多细节。确实如此。哦，是的。有很多很酷的细节，当它们出现时，我们会为你指出来。肯定的。好吧，快速事实二是一个地点解析。我知道这要来了。舒特农场的地点解析。我去过这个农场很多次。让我们听听你有什么。所以我们之前提到过，我们在加利福尼亚州圣克拉丽塔的迪士尼牧场拍摄了舒特农场。我们为这一集回到了那里，这次我们使用了奥利维亚的房子
location, that is the farmhouse that we transformed into Dwight's B&B. Yes, you guys should know this is a vast property, and they have different areas where they film. So they have the barn, right, where you saw the initiation. And then they have little houses and different areas that you can use to create sort of this rustic look for TV and film.
地点，那是我们改造成德怀特民宿的农舍。是的，你们应该知道这是一个广阔的地产，他们有不同的区域可以拍摄。所以他们有谷仓，对吧，你在《入会仪式》中看到的那个。然后他们有小房子和不同的区域，你可以用来为电视和电影创造这种乡村外观。
But these houses, they're just shells. There's nothing in them. Nothing. They're just like exterior shell walls. The walls are not insulated. So it got very, very cold at night. Any of the night scenes,
但这些房子，它们只是外壳。里面什么都没有。什么都没有。它们就像外部的外壳墙。墙壁没有隔热。所以晚上变得非常非常冷。任何夜间场景，
we were freezing. Freezing and drafty and everything is a little bit dusty. Like if you sit on something, like a little cloud of like, poof, yeah, it kind of comes in. out of it. And our set designers had to go in and they had to meticulously decorate every single
我们都冻僵了。冻僵了，而且通风，一切都有点灰尘。就像如果你坐在什么东西上，就像一小团，噗，是的，它有点从里面出来。我们的布景设计师不得不进去，他们不得不一丝不苟地装饰每一个
room. Every item you see we put there. That's right. That's right. I have a feeling they went in first and cleaned and then decorated. Why is my memory of Shrewp Farms so dusty? Well, I remember sneezing a lot. It's dusty. It's old. It's run down. You wouldn't want to lean against the wall. I'll just say that. No. You might go right through it. You might. Now, we have another location in this episode. Michael takes a job as a telemarketer. And I asked Kentapedia about this location. The exterior, when you see him walking into the building, we shot that in Van Nuys.
房间。你看到的每一件物品都是我们放进去的。没错。没错。我有一种感觉，他们先进去打扫，然后装饰。为什么我对舒特农场的记忆那么灰尘？好吧，我记得打了很多喷嚏。它有灰尘。它很旧。它破旧。你不会想靠在墙上的。我只能这么说。不。你可能会直接穿过去。你可能会。现在，我们在这一集中还有另一个地点。迈克尔找了一份电话推销员的工作。我问了肯塔百科（Kentapedia）关于这个地点。外观，当你看到他走进大楼时，我们在范奈斯（Van Nuys）拍摄的。
That was near our studio. But the inside of the building, we shot on the 10th floor of the L.A. Times building in downtown L.A. Now, this shocked me. This shocked me because this building is stunning. stunning. It housed the LA Times until 2017. It was designed by this man named Gordon B. Kaufman in the Art Deco style in the 1930s. It won a gold medal at the 1937 Paris Exposition. And it's just, it's so weird to me that this very, like, ordinary telemarketing office is housed inside of this gorgeous piece of architecture. I know. That is so wild because we don't do that building justice at all. We make it look just like any cubicle office anywhere, right? Yeah. Well, I shot a commercial in my 20s in downtown L.A. And I was really stunned because it was a gorgeous building and we were shooting on like the 12th floor.
那离我们的工作室很近。但大楼内部，我们在洛杉矶市中心的《洛杉矶时报》大楼的10楼拍摄的。现在，这让我震惊。这让我震惊，因为这栋大楼太迷人了。迷人。它在2017年之前一直是《洛杉矶时报》的所在地。它是由一个叫戈登·B·考夫曼（Gordon B. Kaufman）的人在1930年代以装饰艺术风格设计的。它在1937年巴黎博览会上获得了金奖。对我来说，这非常奇怪，这个非常普通的电话推销办公室竟然坐落在这座华丽的建筑杰作中。我知道。这太疯狂了，因为我们根本没有公正地对待那栋建筑。我们让它看起来就像任何地方的任何隔间办公室，对吧？是的。好吧，我在20多岁时在洛杉矶市中心拍过一个广告。我真的很震惊，因为它是一栋华丽的建筑，我们在12楼左右拍摄。
And then they had like craft and service on a different floor. You know, they used a few floors. And it was like three floors in a row with no people, no one. Wow. So I think there are, like sort of buildings downtown that have just a lot of vacancy. Yeah, there must be. I know. It was really eerie because we were filming at night and it was like a dark corridor. I was like, ooh. Well, I visited the LA Times back in college as part of a film and television summer workshop
然后他们在不同的楼层有餐饮服务。你知道，他们用了几层楼。就像连续三层楼没有人，一个人都没有。哇。所以我认为市中心有一些建筑有很多空置。是的，一定有。我知道。这真的很诡异，因为我们是在晚上拍摄的，就像一条黑暗的走廊。我当时想，噢。好吧，我在大学时作为加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）协调的电影和电视暑期研讨会的一部分参观过《洛杉矶时报》。
that was coordinated by UCLA. And we got to go in and see how they make newspapers. And I remember the lobby. It has this great big globe. and I have all these pictures. It was just amazing. I would love that. I would sign up for that. Yeah. I mean, you know, I love a tour. We would sign up for almost any tour, I feel like. We would. I mean, I feel like we could do a podcast where it's just you and I taking tours and talking about today we went to the peanut factory. Oh, lady, that's a brilliant idea. We have to do that. We travel and go on tours and then tell people about the tour we went on.
我们得以进去看看他们是如何制作报纸的。我记得大厅。它有一个巨大的地球仪。我有很多照片。这太棒了。我会喜欢的。我会报名的。是的。我是说，你知道，我喜欢参观。我觉得我们几乎会报名参加任何参观。我们会。我是说，我觉得我们可以做一个播客，就是你和我去参观，谈论今天我们去了花生工厂。哦，女士，那是个绝妙的主意。我们必须这样做。我们旅行去参观，然后告诉人们我们参观的情况。
I mean, selfishly, I want to do that. That sounds great. Okay. Okay, well, speaking of travel, fast fact number three, trip advisor features very heavily in this episode. Yes. And I want you guys to know, we really did create a page on the real trip advisor for Shrut Farms. And our producers made two profiles and gave two reviews. So you could go on after watching the episode and see these two reviews and see these two reviews
我是说，自私地说，我想那样做。听起来很棒。好的。好的，好吧，说到旅行，快速事实三，猫途鹰（TripAdvisor）在这一集中占有重要地位。是的。我想让你们知道，我们确实在真实的猫途鹰上为舒特农场创建了一个页面。我们的制片人制作了两个个人资料并给出了两条评论。所以你可以在看完这一集后去看看这两条评论，看看这两条评论
and see the page, we hear one of them in the episode. That's the one from Jim and Pam, and their profile name was J and P2. Mm-hmm. But the other one that you don't hear in the episode, Angela, was from Sprinkles Mom. I know.
并看到那个页面，我们在这一集中听到了其中一条。那是吉姆和帕姆的那条，他们的个人资料名称是J and P2。嗯哼。但另一条你在这一集中听不到的，安吉拉，是来自Sprinkles Mom的。我知道。
And it's a really negative review. It's very negative. Did you find it too? I did. It says, stay away. Propriator is crazy. Oh my gosh. You have to read it.
而且这是一条非常负面的评论。非常负面。你也找到了吗？我找到了。它说，远离这里。老板是个疯子。天哪。你必须读一下。
You have to read it. Okay. It says, I have to warn people about the proprietor of Shrewt Farms. He may portray himself as a gentleman farmer, but he is not what he seems. He killed my cat sprinkles. Who knows what he might do to you or your loved ones? Oh. So the profiles are no longer there, and those reviews are no longer there, but Shrewt Farms is still a page on TripAdvisor.
你必须读一下。好的。它说，我必须警告人们关于舒特农场的老板。他可能把自己描绘成一个绅士农场主，但他不是他看起来的那样。他杀死了我的猫Sprinkles。谁知道他会对你或你所爱的人做什么？哦。所以个人资料不再在那里了，那些评论也不再在那里了，但舒特农场仍然是猫途鹰上的一个页面。
It has over 1,300 reviews, and it has four stars. I went on the Shrewp Farms TripAdvisor page, and I want you guys to know, it's got a little write-up, it's got a photo. This is something that cracked me up. It says, here are the languages spoken at Shrewp Farms. Are you ready? I'm ready. Now, we know this is just Dwight and Moes, but here are the languages spoken. Okay.
它有超过1300条评论，而且有四颗星。我去了舒特农场的猫途鹰页面，我想让你们知道，它有一个小简介，有一张照片。这是让我笑喷的一件事。它说，这是舒特农场使用的语言。准备好了吗？我准备好了。现在，我们知道这只是德怀特和莫斯（Mose），但这是使用的语言。好的。
Azarbanji, Bosnian, Burmese, Hebrew, Hindi, Hungarian, Icelandic, Portuguese, oddly not on the list is German. and Dwight answers the phone, Guten Tog. Uh-huh. So, TripAdvisor, you might want to update that. And TripAdvisor's like, guys, this is real. We just agreed to do it. And then the other thing I thought was kind of cool about this, and it's a little bit of a callback.
阿塞拜疆语、波斯尼亚语、缅甸语、希伯来语、印地语、匈牙利语、冰岛语、葡萄牙语，奇怪的是名单上没有德语。而德怀特接电话时说，Guten Tog（你好）。嗯哼。所以，猫途鹰，你们可能想更新一下。而猫途鹰就像是，伙计们，这是真的。我们只是同意这样做。然后我觉得关于这个的另一件很酷的事情，这是一个小小的呼应。
This was also a task in the Dunder Mifflin Infinity online game. Posting review of Shrewp Farms was part of Dunder Mifflin Infinity's game on their website. That is so cool. And you can still post, as Jenna said, your review today, and I just read one as recent as December 2020. Someone made up a review. Now, I read one, Angela, and I wasn't sure if it was real or not. Oh, yeah?
这也是《办公室》在线游戏中的一个任务。发布舒特农场的评论是《办公室》网站游戏的一部分。这太酷了。而且正如珍娜所说，你今天仍然可以发布你的评论，我刚刚读到一条2020年12月的最新评论。有人编造了一条评论。现在，我读了一条，安吉拉，我不确定它是真是假。哦，是吗？
But a person wrote, guys, this place is not real. I drove all the way there, and there is nothing there, and I was very disappointed. Oh, no. And I was like, wait, wait, did this person really drive to this weird remote location in Pennsylvania, hoping to find fruit farms? You've got to know there's at least one person, right, that doesn't know that it was part of the show and just is wanting to go see it, right?
但一个人写道，伙计们，这个地方不是真的。我一路开车到那里，那里什么都没有，我非常失望。哦，不。我当时想，等等，等等，这个人真的开车去了宾夕法尼亚州那个奇怪的偏远地方，希望能找到舒特农场吗？你必须知道至少有一个人，对吧，不知道它是节目的一部分，只是想去看看，对吧？
Yeah. Oh, sorry person who drove there. Sorry, buddy. Well, that's all I got, lady. Well, I thought those were fantastic fast facts. No judgey. No judgey, lady. Oh, I get a no judgey.
是的。哦，抱歉那个开车去的人。抱歉，伙计。好吧，这就是我所有的了，女士。好吧，我觉得那些是精彩的快速事实。没有评判。没有评判，女士。哦，我得到了一个没有评判。
A no judgey for you today. That is high praise. Well, before we go to break, we have some great news to share with you guys. It's very exciting. I'm very excited. I'm very excited. Thanks to the Office Ladies fans.
今天为你准备了一个没有评判。那是很高的赞扬。好吧，在我们休息之前，我们有一些好消息要和你们分享。非常令人兴奋。我非常兴奋。我非常兴奋。多亏了《办公室女士》的粉丝们。
We won IHeart Radio's podcast of the year. Podcast of the year, guys. Woo! On the year. Thank you so much for voting for us. You really have no idea how excited we are about this. We are very, very proud. I mean, lady, we put our heart into this podcast every week.
我们赢得了IHeart Radio的年度播客。年度播客，伙计们。呜！年度。非常感谢你们为我们投票。你们真的不知道我们对此有多兴奋。我们非常非常自豪。我是说，女士，我们每周都把心血投入到这个播客中。
We do. And I am going to cherish this. a word and put it in a very prominent spot. I'm going to make people pass by it and ask me what it is whenever they come to my house. Oh. I'm going to be super braggy about it and I'm not going to apologize. No, you are not. This just means the world to us. You know, we love this show. We love rewatching it. We love the community that has come here to do this journey with us. And we get to work with our best friend. You guys, it's such a blessing. I am so thankful. I have such a gratitude. I already know where I'm putting mine. I'm putting mine right between my tight-ass
我们确实。而且我会珍惜这个奖项，把它放在一个非常显眼的地方。我会让人们经过它，当他们来到我家时问我那是什么。哦。我会对此非常吹嘘，而且我不会道歉。不，你不会。这对我们来说意味着全世界。你知道，我们喜欢这个节目。我们喜欢重温它。我们喜欢来到这里和我们一起踏上这段旅程的社区。而且我们能和我们最好的朋友一起工作。伙计们，这真是一种福气。我非常感谢。我心存感激。我已经知道我要把我的放在哪里了。我要把它放在我的“紧屁股”
Dundee Award and my She's Kind of a Bitch Award. Those are my two Dundies and it's going right in between them. Well, you're going to trip over mine when you walk through my door. That's where mine's going. It's going on the floor. Right in front of my door so that everyone has to say what's that as they walk into my house. So there you go. It's going to be a really weird spot. Thank you guys so much. It really means a lot. Yeah. Thank you. All right. We'll take a break and we'll be back in just a moment. Okay, so we are back and this scene starts with Michael walking in and he just throws his coat on Pam. And I know it's what you're all here for, but at one second, there's a fantastic shot. Of the plant at Front Reception, tell us all about it.
邓迪奖（Dundee Award）和我的“她有点像个婊子”奖之间。那是我的两个邓迪奖，它会正好放在它们中间。好吧，当你走进我的门时，你会绊倒我的。那就是我的要去的地方。它会放在地板上。就在我的门前，这样每个人在走进我家时都必须说那是什么。所以就是这样。那会是一个非常奇怪的地方。非常感谢你们。这真的意义重大。是的。谢谢。好吧。我们休息一下，一会儿回来。好的，我们回来了，这一幕以迈克尔走进来开始，他只是把外套扔在帕姆身上。我知道这是你们所有人来这里的原因，但在第一秒，有一个精彩的镜头。关于前台的植物，告诉我们一切。
Okay, it's got an orange pot, and I'm very curious what kind of plant this is. It's got very skinny stems and then kind of wispy, fluffy leaves. What kind of plan is that? My plant people hit me up, I want to know. Well, when I spoke with Steve, our set decorator, he told me that most of the plants that he put at reception were of the vine variety because they did not flower and they stayed pretty consistent for a whole week. Well, I am familiar with the vine plants, and I don't know what this one is. So our Beasley botanical experts out there, hit me up. Let me know what kind of plant that is.
好的，它有一个橙色的花盆，我很好奇这是什么植物。它有非常细的茎，然后是那种飘逸的、毛茸茸的叶子。那是什么植物？我的植物专家们联系我，我想知道。好吧，当我与我们的布景装饰师史蒂夫（Steve）交谈时，他告诉我，他放在前台的大多数植物都是藤本植物，因为它们不开花，而且在一周内保持相当一致。好吧，我熟悉藤本植物，我不知道这是哪一种。所以我们外面的比斯利（Beasley）植物专家们，联系我。让我知道那是什么植物。
It's at one second. Thank you. Well, this whole cold open is very funny. We find out from Pam in a talking head that Michael has been watching the movie The Devil Wares Prada. But he doesn't watch it all at once. He watches it in little clips. He's a big Merrill Street fan.
在第一秒。谢谢。好吧，整个冷开场非常有趣。我们从帕姆的一个谈话头中发现，迈克尔一直在看电影《穿普拉达的女王》（The Devil Wears Prada）。但他不是一次看完。他分小片段看。他是梅丽尔·斯特里普（Meryl Streep）的超级粉丝。
So he's clearly identified with her character, and now he is treating Pam the way Merrill Street treats her employees in the film. It cracks me up that he watches it in little clips because if you really look at the scene, you can tell. Because he clearly just sees the part where she goes, steak, give me a steak, you know? So he'll just come out and sort of like just regurgitate what he just watched in like 10 seconds. Well, we had a fan question about this from Amy S. Louise M. Ln. P. and Hannah C. Was John Krasinski with Emily Blunt yet when Michael does these references to the Devil Where's Prada or was it just a coincidence?
所以他显然认同了她的角色，现在他正在用梅丽尔·斯特里普在电影中对待员工的方式对待帕姆。他分小片段看让我笑喷了，因为如果你真的看那一幕，你可以看出来。因为他显然只是看到了她去的那部分，牛排，给我一块牛排，你知道吗？所以他只是出来，有点像是把他刚刚在10秒钟内看到的东西复述出来。好吧，我们有一个来自艾米·S、路易丝·M、Ln. P.和汉娜·C的粉丝问题。当迈克尔做这些《穿普拉达的女王》的参考时，约翰·卡拉辛斯基（John Krasinski）和艾米莉·布朗特（Emily Blunt）在一起了吗，还是只是巧合？
It was a coincidence, you guys. I watched this with my daughter and Isabel said, Mom, Devil Wears Prada. Isn't that John's wife? Yeah. Well, listen, this is not the only coincidence and it brings up a a very interesting set of trivia that I have called Six Degrees of Devil Wears Prada. Oh, I am in it.
这是一个巧合，伙计们。我和我女儿一起看了这个，伊莎贝尔说，妈妈，《穿普拉达的女王》。那不是约翰的妻子吗？是的。好吧，听着，这不仅仅是巧合，它引出了一个我称之为《穿普拉达的女王》六度分隔的非常有趣的琐事。哦，我在里面。
Let's hear it. The Office cast has a lot of connections to the cast of the Devil Wers Prada. Do you want to hear them? Yes, because I can only think of two. Okay, go. All right, well, we know that John Krasinski will marry Emily Blunt.
让我们听听。办公室演员阵容与《穿普拉达的女王》演员阵容有很多联系。你想听听吗？是的，因为我只能想到两个。好的，说。好吧，好吧，我们知道约翰·卡拉辛斯基会娶艾米莉·布朗特。
Mm-hmm. Steve Karell will go on after this episode to star in Get Smart with Anne Hathaway. Ah. Rain Wilson was in entourage with Adrian Grenier. Oh, that's a good one. Rich Summer, who was also in Devil Wears Prada, will later appear on the office as Pam's art school friend.
嗯哼。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）在这一集之后会去和安妮·海瑟薇（Anne Hathaway）主演《糊涂侦探》（Get Smart）。啊。雷恩·威尔森（Rain Wilson）和阿德里安·格尼尔（Adrian Grenier）一起出演了《明星伙伴》（Entourage）。哦，那是一个很好的。里奇·萨默（Rich Sommer），他也出演了《穿普拉达的女王》，后来会作为帕姆的艺术学校朋友出现在《办公室》里。
And listen to this one. The movie The Devil Wears Prada was based on a book written by Lauren Weisberger, and she's from Scranton. What? Yeah. Angela, you and I will eventually fake laugh at an award show with Meryl Streep. We will.
听听这个。电影《穿普拉达的女王》是根据劳伦·魏丝伯格（Lauren Weisberger）写的一本书改编的，她是斯克兰顿人。什么？是的。安吉拉，你和我最终会在颁奖典礼上和梅丽尔·斯特里普假笑。我们会。
I feel like that counts. She will have no idea and does not remember that moment, but we did walk up to her fake laughing. And finally, this one's a little bit of a stretch, but Stanley Tucci will marry Emily Blunt's sister
我觉得这算数。她会完全不知道，也不记得那一刻，但我们确实走到她面前假笑。最后，这个有点牵强，但斯坦利·图齐（Stanley Tucci）会娶艾米莉·布朗特的妹妹
in real life. That's the other one I was thinking of. I love that, by the way, that that's a stretch, but us laughing adjacent to Meryl Streep is not a stretch. Okay. I want you guys to
在现实生活中。那是我在想的另一个。顺便说一句，我喜欢那个，那是牵强，但我们在梅丽尔·斯特里普旁边笑不是牵强。好的。我想让你们
to know, though, a few months ago, this video went viral of Stanley Tucci making a cocktail. It is fantastic. I highly recommend you watch it start to finish. He just seems really cool. It's like, I want to hang out with Stanley Tucci in his kitchen. Yes, I want to sit on a stool in his kitchen while he makes me a cocktail. Yes, everyone does. Stanley Tucci, you heard that. So you're going to have two uninvited guests at some point. We'll be over soon. So this cold open ends with a Pam talking head. That is really funny. And Jenna, I want you to check out the bloopers because you and Paul Lieberstein. You can hear him laughing off camera. The two of you could not get through this talking head. About million dollar baby, you kept cracking up. Yes, when Pam has to realize
知道，几个月前，这个斯坦利·图齐制作鸡尾酒的视频疯传。太棒了。我强烈建议你从头到尾看一遍。他看起来真的很酷。就像，我想和斯坦利·图齐在他的厨房里闲逛。是的，我想坐在他厨房的凳子上，当他为我制作鸡尾酒时。是的，每个人都想。斯坦利·图齐，你听到了。所以你会在某个时候有两个不速之客。我们很快就会过去。所以这个冷开场以帕姆的一个谈话头结束。这真的很有趣。珍娜，我想让你看看花絮，因为你和保罗·利伯斯坦。你可以听到他在镜头外笑。你们两个无法完成这个谈话头。关于《百万美元宝贝》（Million Dollar Baby），你们一直笑个不停。是的，当帕姆意识到
that Michael is going to kill her, we couldn't get through it. We couldn't get through it. I couldn't hold it long enough afterwards without laughing. Well, it's hilarious and there's fun bloopers. You can check it out. Well, this episode opened. with Michael and Jan. Jan's in another juicy couture track suit. And it's all she wears now. And yeah, absolutely. And they're picking out fabric for the condo.
迈克尔要杀了她时，我们无法完成它。我们无法完成它。之后我无法忍住不笑。好吧，这太搞笑了，而且有有趣的花絮。你可以看看。好吧，这一集以迈克尔和简开始。简穿着另一套Juicy Couture运动服。这是她现在穿的唯一衣服。而且是的，绝对。他们正在为公寓挑选布料。
They're doing some redecorating. Yeah, there's a whole runner in deleted scenes where she comes in with this box of all this sort of fabric and curtain and all this kind of like samples. And Michael is just avoiding going into his office to talk to her. He like starts talking to Phyllis out of nowhere and Stanley and they're like, what are you doing? Jan's waiting for you. Well, he has a talking head where he explains why he might be avoiding things because money is really tight.
他们正在重新装修。是的，在删减片段中有一个完整的跑动，她带着这盒各种布料、窗帘和所有这些样品进来。而迈克尔只是在避免进入他的办公室和她说话。他开始没来由地和菲利斯（Phyllis）说话，还有斯坦利，他们就像，你在做什么？简在等你。好吧，他有一个谈话头，解释了他为什么可能在回避事情，因为钱真的很紧。
Jan is insisting that they spend all this money redecorating the condo. But you know, at the end of his life, when he's sitting on his yacht, he's not going to be thinking about money. He's going to be thinking about how many friends he has and his children and his comedy albums. And by the way, he has a yacht, so he probably did pretty well, money-wise. I thought that was so funny. Well, Jenna, as I remember, you have some very strong feelings on yachts and yacht ownership. I do. I don't get it. There was this time when I felt like every time I opened Instagram, every celebrity was like yachting. They were getting on a yacht. And I was like, what is this world? I don't get it.
简坚持要他们花所有的钱重新装修公寓。但你知道，在他生命的尽头，当他坐在游艇上时，他不会想到钱。他会想到他有多少朋友，他的孩子和他的喜剧专辑。顺便说一句，他有一艘游艇，所以他在金钱方面可能做得很好。我觉得那太搞笑了。好吧，珍娜，我记得，你对游艇和游艇所有权有非常强烈的感受。我有。我不明白。有一次我觉得每次我打开Instagram，每个名人都在游艇上。他们正在上一艘游艇。我当时想，这是什么世界？我不明白。
This yachting vacation world. You're cooped up in a small space on water. I have to imagine you get seasick. And there's a crew right on top of you. Like, I like privacy when I'm on vacation. I don't, I mean, listen, that's a whole other thing that I have. And I think it's because I spent so much time in the service industry being a caterer or whatever. You know, people don't see you when you're a caterer or something, when you're bringing them
这个游艇度假世界。你被关在水上的一个小空间里。我不得不想象你会晕船。而且有一个船员就在你上面。我是说，我在度假时喜欢隐私。我不，我是说，听着，那是我的另一回事。而且我认为这是因为我在服务行业花了很多时间做餐饮服务员什么的。你知道，当你做餐饮服务员时，人们看不到你，或者当你给他们带来
the drinks and the hors d'oeuvres. But newsflash, we can actually hear you and see you and everything you're doing. And I can't tell you how many, like, fancy Hollywood parties I catered. I observed so much stuff. People just act like you're invisible. I wouldn't be able to relax on a yacht. I wouldn't be able to relax because I would know that they're watching me. They're listening. I love it. How do these celebrities behave this way on yachts? How are they relaxed? I don't get it. I don't get it. You're pivot about yachting.
饮料和开胃菜时。但新闻快报，我们实际上可以听到你，看到你，以及你正在做的一切。我无法告诉你我为多少高级好莱坞派对提供过餐饮。我观察到了很多东西。人们只是表现得好像你是隐形的。我无法在游艇上放松。我无法放松，因为我知道他们在看着我。他们在听。我喜欢它。这些名人怎么在游艇上表现得这样？他们怎么放松的？我不明白。我不明白。你关于游艇的转折。
Like, I thought, I thought we're going to talk about how it seems wasteful to spend that much money on a boat, but you're like, but also they're watching you. They're watching you. No, it is also, I don't get that part. But ultimately, I think what it is is that I like cities and museums and I like walking on my vacations. I'm not a, I'm not like a sit on a boat and take selfies person. Like, that doesn't, no, that's not for me. I love a boat. I love the ocean.
我是说，我以为，我以为我们要谈论在船上花那么多钱看起来多么浪费，但你就像，但他们也在看着你。他们在看着你。不，那也是，我不明白那部分。但最终，我认为是因为我喜欢城市和博物馆，我喜欢在度假时走路。我不是那种坐在船上自拍的人。我是说，那不，不，那不适合我。我喜欢船。我喜欢海洋。
I love getting out on the ocean, but I don't need to vacation in the boat. Do you know what I mean? Like, I like to be on land, but then take the boat places like adventures. Yes, like you would want to go diving or snorkeling. Yes, yes. But then return to land for the sleeping part. Yes, and the hanging out part and the eating and all that. Yeah.
我喜欢出海，但我不需要在船上度假。你知道我的意思吗？我是说，我喜欢在陆地上，但然后把船带到像冒险一样的地方。是的，就像你会想去潜水或浮潜。是的，是的。但然后回到陆地睡觉。是的，还有闲逛和吃饭等等。是的。
Well, we're not yachters. We've proved that. You know what you're not going to hear on office ladies? An ad for yachting. You know what else you're not going to hear? Oh my God. I was on the most fabulous yacht. Oh my God.
好吧，我们不是游艇爱好者。我们证明了这一点。你知道你在《办公室女士》中不会听到什么吗？游艇广告。你知道你还不会听到什么吗？天哪。我在最棒的游艇上。天哪。
Cut to two years from now when like we're yachting. And we're on a yacht. That's what happens in the universe. You put something out there and you're like, I would never. And then all of a sudden the universe is like jokes on you. You're a yachter. We get invited to tour the. factory where they make yachts and we love them and they take us out on one and then we take a
切到两年后，当我们像在游艇上一样。我们在游艇上。这就是宇宙中发生的事情。你把某样东西放出来，你就像，我绝不会。然后突然宇宙就像开你的玩笑。你是一个游艇爱好者。我们被邀请参观制造游艇的工厂，我们喜欢它们，他们带我们出去，然后我们在游艇上自拍。听着，我很乐意参观游艇工厂。我知道，我也想。所以现在我们在吉姆和德怀特的办公桌区，吉姆无意中听到德怀特接听听起来像是民宿预订的电话。吉姆就像，什么，什么，发生了什么？这太搞笑了，吉姆显然在和某人通话或刚刚打了一个电话，他挂断了，以便更好地专注于德怀特的电话。是的，这真的很好。对于我们的背景发现者，有一个德怀特电脑屏幕的精彩镜头，它看起来就像一个纸质订单。所以道具组干得好。你看不到雷恩实际上在互联网上浏览什么。我在3分30秒在接待处的背景里还有几个其他的背景发现。我正在对我们的摄像师兰德尔（Randall）微笑。
selfie on a yacht. Listen, I would love a yacht factory tour. I know, I would too. So now we're at Jim and Dwight's desk pod and Jim overhears Dwight taking what sounds like a reservation for a bed and breakfast. And Jim's like, what, what, what's happening? It's so funny, Jim is clearly on hold with someone or has just made a call and he hangs up so he can better focus on Dwight's phone call. Yeah, it's really good. And for our background catchers, there is a great shot of Dwight's computer screen and it just looks like a paper order. So way to go props. You can't see what Rain was actually surfing on the internet. I have a couple of other background catches here at three minutes, 30 seconds in the background at reception. I am smiling at Randall our camera operator.
哦。我没意识到我们已经开始拍摄了。哦，那太可爱了。所以你可以看到我和兰德尔分享了一个时刻，然后迅速进入角色。同样在背景中，在克里德（Creed）的电脑上，他正在玩一场史诗般的纸牌游戏。听起来很对。嗯哼。好吧，德怀特有一个关于农业旅游的谈话头，它不仅仅是一个民宿。
Oh. I didn't realize we had started rolling. Oh, that's so cute. So you can see me share a moment with Randall and then quickly get into character. Also in the background on Creed's computer, he is playing an epic game of solitaire. That sounds about right. Mm-hmm. Well, Dwight has this talking head about agro-tourism, and it's more than just a B&B.
噢。我没意识到我们已经开始录制了。噢，那太可爱了。所以你可以看到我和兰德尔分享了一个瞬间，然后迅速进入角色。另外在背景里，克里德的电脑上正在玩一场史诗级的纸牌游戏。这听起来很符合他的风格。嗯哼。好吧，德怀特有一个关于农业旅游的访谈片段，那不仅仅是一家民宿。
It's about people visiting a farm and you give them a bed, and it's like a whole experience. And Pam calls to sort of make a phone. fake reservation, but ends up like booking a trip to Shroup Farms. Yeah. It's going to be Jim and Pam's first night away together. Okay. I love that, actually. I think that's super sweet.
这讲的是人们去农场参观，你给他们提供床位，这就像是一种完整的体验。帕姆打电话去假装预订，结果却真的订了一次去施鲁特农场的旅行。没错。这将是吉姆和帕姆第一次一起在外过夜。好的。我其实很喜欢这个主意。我觉得这超级贴心。
Well, it's definitely like a weekend they'll never forget. Michael has a talking head where explains they used to have two cars, but they traded them in. Now they just have one, and the new car is a Porsche for Jan. Yeah. I mean, Jan is just dismantling his whole life. And when he says, I need the car tonight, she's like, for your improv, can't you just improv driving there or take the bus? Like, she doesn't even know where he's going or what he's doing. She has no idea the big hole financially that she's creating and how he is scrambling. Yeah, I know. It's very sad. It made me sad. Well, we had a fan catch here from Matthew L. Colby Shannon, Joseph Stevens, Catherine A. and McKenna H., among others, who said, Michael says that they traded in both of their cars to buy a Porsche for Jan, but wasn't Michael Sebring a company lease? How would he have traded it in?
嗯，这绝对是一个他们永远不会忘记的周末。迈克尔有一个采访镜头，解释说他们以前有两辆车，但他们把车卖了。现在他们只有一辆，而那辆新车是给简买的保时捷。是啊。我的意思是，简简直是在拆解他整个人生。当他说“我今晚需要用车”时，她说“为了你的即兴表演，你就不能即兴发挥开车去那里，或者坐公交车吗？”她甚至不知道他要去哪儿，在做什么。她根本不知道自己在经济上造成了多大的亏空，也不知道他现在有多么手忙脚乱。是啊，我知道。这很可悲。这让我感到难过。好吧，我们这里有一位粉丝的发现，来自马修·L、科尔比·香农、约瑟夫·史蒂文斯、凯瑟琳·A和麦肯娜·H等人，他们说，迈克尔说他们卖掉了两辆车给简买了一辆保时捷，但迈克尔的赛百灵不是公司租赁的吗？他怎么能把它卖掉呢？
Hmm, good catch. Maybe if you don't take the company car, you get some sort of cash credit and he used that for the Porsche. That sounds like a good theory. Do we like that? I made that up just now. I like it very much. Okay. Well, now, lady, we've got this great scene of you and Dwight in the parking lot.
嗯，好眼力。也许如果你不选公司配车，你会得到某种现金抵扣，他把那个用在了保时捷上。这听起来是个不错的理论。我们喜欢这个说法吗？我刚才现编的。我非常喜欢。好的，那么，女士，我们有一段你和德怀特在停车场的精彩戏份。
You're getting some of your belongings back. Yes. Dwight gives Angela her cardigan, her sleeping cardigan, her sleep apnea mask. And then Angela asks, well, where's my chair figurine? And Dwight says, I don't know what you're talking about. You, you know, you didn't leave it there. I looked all over. I've scrubbed the room of your memory.
你拿回了一些你的物品。是的。德怀特把安吉拉的开衫、她的睡眠开衫、她的睡眠呼吸暂停面罩还给了她。然后安吉拉问，那么，我的椅子小雕像呢？德怀特说，我不知道你在说什么。你，你知道，你没把它留在那里。我到处都找过了。我已经清除了你留在房间里的记忆。
And she's like, huh, fine. Well, I had a few questions about these items. For example, the sleeping cardigan. Yeah. Is it a thing? Let me tell you, because I Googled it. Oh. It is.
她说，呵，好吧。关于这些物品，我还有几个问题。例如，睡眠开衫。是啊。真有这种东西吗？让我告诉你，因为我谷歌了一下。哦。确实有。
So if you type in sleeping cardigan on Google, one of the first things that comes up is a sleep sweater from Target. What? How do you not already know about this? I don't know. Target expert. I know. It said sleeping sweaters. You can get them at Target. Sleeping sweaters.
所以如果你在谷歌上输入“睡眠开衫”，最先出现的结果之一就是塔吉特百货的睡眠毛衣。什么？你怎么会不知道这个？我不知道。塔吉特专家。我知道。上面写着“睡眠毛衣”。你可以在塔吉特买到它们。睡眠毛衣。
Well, I shot a movie in Detroit. It was the movie that I fell in love with Lee, giant mechanical man, and it was very cold, and we were staying in this hotel, and I could not get warm, and I wore a sweater to bed and a hat. I was like fully dressed when I went to sleep. Oh, I go to sleep with like three layers on and Josh is in like his undies. Well, it's ridiculous. You clearly need a sleeping cardigan from Target.
嗯，我在底特律拍过一部电影。就是那部让我爱上李的电影，《巨型机械人》，当时非常冷，我们住在一家酒店里，我怎么也暖和不起来，于是我穿着毛衣和帽子睡觉。我睡觉的时候简直是全副武装。哦，我睡觉时会穿三层，而乔什只穿内衣。嗯，这太荒谬了。你显然需要一件塔吉特的睡眠开衫。
I guess I need a sleep sweater is what Target calls it. And then Angela also gets her sleep apnea mask back. Do we find out that Angela has sleep apnea? I mean, this is a serious sleep disorder. Well, we got a fan question from Rachel Nielsen about that. She was very surprised when Dwight handed Angela the CPAP machine. She said, as someone who used to work in the sleep disorder industry, this was very interesting to me because Angela does not fit the typical CPAP profile.
我想我需要一件塔吉特所说的“睡眠毛衣”。然后安吉拉也拿回了她的睡眠呼吸暂停面罩。我们发现安吉拉有睡眠呼吸暂停症了吗？我的意思是，这是一种严重的睡眠障碍。嗯，我们收到了瑞秋·尼尔森关于这个问题的粉丝提问。当德怀特把CPAP呼吸机递给安吉拉时，她非常惊讶。她说，作为一个曾经在睡眠障碍行业工作过的人，这对我来说非常有趣，因为安吉拉并不符合典型的CPAP用户特征。
I would have thought Dwight used it. Was there any thought processor backstory for Angela on this, or was this a total surprise? No backstory for me. I think this made the writer's room chuckle, and it went in the script. Well, I feel very worried for Angela knowing now that she hasn't had her sleep apnea machine for a while. I know. this caused me to feel anxious. I don't like thinking that people are without the necessary tools or medicines that they need for any period of time. You know what really bothers me? What? It really bothers me if I'm watching a movie and someone gets even a minor injury and they don't deal with it immediately. It really, I'm very distracted by it. Like someone gets a cut and they don't like wrap it up right. It happens a lot in action films and it really bugs me. But what really is, bothers me is after someone gets an injury when the villain presses on the injury.
我本来以为是德怀特在用。对于安吉拉的这个设定，有什么构思过程或背景故事吗，还是这完全是个惊喜？对我来说没有背景故事。我想这让编剧室笑出了声，于是就写进了剧本里。嗯，想到安吉拉有一段时间没有用她的睡眠呼吸暂停呼吸机，我感到非常担心。我知道。这让我感到焦虑。我不喜欢想到人们在任何一段时间内都缺乏他们所需的必要工具或药物。你知道什么真的困扰我吗？什么？如果我在看电影，有人受了哪怕是轻伤，而他们没有立即处理，这真的让我很困扰。真的，我会被它分散注意力。比如有人被割伤了，他们没有包扎好。这在动作片中经常发生，真的很让我烦心。但真正困扰我的是，当有人受伤后，反派按压伤口的时候。
You know, like someone gets like a bullet to the shoulder and then when they're being interrogated by the villain, the villain presses on their wound. I can't. It's the hebe-jeebies for me and I can't deal with it. Well, do not watch the show alone where they drop people off in the middle of nowhere and they have to just survive because they get injured and they have to try to patch it up on their own. If it gets really bad, they send a medic in, but it's got to get bad for the medic to like chop her in. No. You couldn't do it.
你知道，就像有人肩膀中了一枪，然后当他们被反派审问时，反派按压他们的伤口。我受不了。这让我毛骨悚然，我无法接受。好吧，千万别看那个把人扔在荒郊野外让他们自生自灭的节目，因为他们受伤了，不得不尝试自己包扎。如果情况真的很糟糕，他们会派一名医护人员进去，但必须得情况很糟，医护人员才会介入。不。你做不到的。
See, I can't. I couldn't do it. And then you, you know, of course, you're constantly seeing like their banged up thumb as they try to fish. Yeah, this is what I'm saying. I can't. You can't do it. You can't do it.
看，我做不到。我做不到。然后你，你知道，当然，你会一直看到他们钓鱼时那根受伤的拇指。是啊，这就是我说的。我做不到。你做不到。你做不到。
No. Well, the last thing on the list, of course, is the chair of figurine. And I want you guys to know, I own one. Do you have the one from the show? No, no. It's so funny to me. I was given one as a gift. I don't know when even like in.
不。好吧，清单上的最后一项，当然是椅子小雕像。我想让你们知道，我有一个。你有剧里的那个吗？不，不。这对我来说太搞笑了。我收到过一个作为礼物。我甚至不知道是什么时候，在……
high school from like, I don't know, Aunt Brenda, did you give it to me? Anyway, I have a little chair figurine and it went with me to college and sat on my window seal and it made its way all the way to California. And it was on my dresser with like my dresser in the bedroom and I need to go see if it's still there because at some point, Isabel thought it was cute and then Isabel would like, like, I think put it in her room. I'm trying to track it down, guys. Anyway, long boring story to tell you in real life I have a chair of figurine. rain. Also at six minutes and 24 seconds in this scene, Angela, you are wearing very high heels. Why? So high. Oh, probably because I had to stand next to rain because normally in my scenes with him,
高中时，可能是布伦达阿姨给我的？不管怎样，我有一个小椅子雕像，它跟着我去了大学，坐在我的窗台上，然后一路跟着我到了加州。它放在我卧室的梳妆台上，我得去看看它还在不在，因为有一次，伊莎贝尔觉得它很可爱，然后伊莎贝尔好像把它放进了她的房间。我正在追踪它的下落，伙计们。不管怎样，这是一个漫长而无聊的故事，告诉你现实生活中我有一个椅子小雕像。雷恩。另外，在这一幕的6分24秒，安吉拉，你穿着非常高的高跟鞋。为什么？这么高。哦，可能是因为我必须站在雷恩旁边，因为通常我和他的对手戏中，
he's seated. And if I have to stand next to him, he's six three, I am five one. You get the big heels, get brought out. Well, these were massive. Guys, check it out, six minutes, 24 seconds. And also, if you toggle back to six minutes, nine seconds, there's a, great shot of my cat hair clip that Kim Ferry, who did my hair, made herself with like a glue gun. And years later, she gave it to me in a shadow box and I have my cat hair clips. Aw, I know. So now we're going to move on to the scene where Kevin makes a big announcement to the bullpen that he would really love them to come see his band. It's like a battle of the band's night. And there's going to be an applause meter and he will only win by clapping
他是坐着的。如果我必须站在他旁边，他身高6英尺3英寸，我只有5英尺1英寸。你得穿上高跟鞋，被带出来。嗯，这些鞋子太巨大了。伙计们，去看看，6分24秒。还有，如果你切换回6分09秒，有一个我猫咪发夹的特写镜头，那是负责我发型的金·费里用胶枪自己做的。多年后，她把它放在一个阴影盒里送给了我，现在我有我的猫咪发夹了。啊。我知道。所以现在我们要进入凯文向办公室大厅宣布他非常希望他们来看他乐队演出的场景。那就像是一个乐队之夜。会有一个掌声测量仪，他只能靠鼓掌获胜，
and he wants everyone to come and clap for his band, Scrantonicity 2, not Scrantonicity, which he is no longer a part of. There is clearly some bad blood that we don't know about. But he invites the whole office to please come. Well, we had a fan question about this. Okay. From Naomi Y., Beatrice W., M. Raines, Alison Quigley, and Elizabeth Shannon. They said, why didn't Pam go see Kevin's band?
他希望每个人都来为他的乐队“Scrantonicity 2”鼓掌，而不是“Scrantonicity”，他已经不再是那个乐队的一员了。显然有一些我们不知道的过节。但他邀请整个办公室的人一定要来。嗯，我们有一个关于这个的粉丝提问。好的。来自娜奥米·Y、比阿特丽斯·W、M·雷恩斯、艾莉森·奎格利和伊丽莎白·香农。他们问，为什么帕姆没去看凯文的乐队演出？
No one came to her art show and she felt so hurt. Wouldn't she want to see Kevin so he wouldn't feel unsupported the way she did? Wow, that's a really good call. Yeah. Here's what I'm thinking, guys. I'm thinking maybe she has gone to see his band. Maybe she went to go see Scranton a city. Maybe everyone in the office has gone to see it.
没有人来看她的艺术展，她感到非常受伤。难道她不想去看凯文，让他不至于像她那样感到不被支持吗？哇，这问得真好。是啊。伙计们，我是这么想的。我在想也许她已经去看过他的乐队了。也许她去看过“Scrantonicity”。也许办公室里的每个人都去看过。
And this is like another request to come see the band. You know those people, right? Like they're in the pan or they do stand up. And you're like, dude, I've seen seven of your standup shows. Like, I can't come to this one tonight. I just can't do it. Maybe that's what's happening. I think I was this person because I was always in an improv show.
而这就像是又一次来看乐队的请求。你知道那种人，对吧？他们组乐队或者做单口喜剧。然后你会说，伙计，我已经看过你七场单口喜剧表演了。我今晚真的去不了。我就是去不了。也许这就是正在发生的事情。我想我就是那个人，因为我总是在做即兴表演。
I was always like, hey, catch my improv show. And people are like, you perform three times a week for like the last four years. I can't come see you do improv anymore. Stop asking me. I can relate too because I did all that stuff too. And I know that especially with stand-up, like at least at the level that I was performing. Guys, I didn't do stand-up. I did this really weird comedic magic show.
我总是说，嘿，来看我的即兴表演吧。然后人们会说，你过去四年里每周表演三次。我不能再来看你做即兴表演了。别再问我了。我也能感同身受，因为我也做过所有那些事。而且我知道，特别是单口喜剧，至少在我表演的那个水平上。伙计们，我没做过单口喜剧。我做了一个非常奇怪的喜剧魔术表演。
I won't go down that rabbit hole now. What? Yeah. What? I did. It was like a, I was a silent comedic. magician. What? And I performed to music in comedy clubs. Jenna, this is so amazing. I cannot believe I didn't know this about you. We've been friends for so long. You were like a comedic
我现在不想钻那个牛角尖。什么？是啊。什么？我做过。那就像是一个，我是一个沉默的喜剧魔术师。什么？我在喜剧俱乐部伴着音乐表演。珍娜，这太神奇了。我简直不敢相信我不知道你的这件事。我们做朋友这么久了。你就像一个喜剧
mime. Yeah. What? I would give anything to see that. Anything. I did magic tricks using my hands. Oh, God. And they weren't really magic. It was a joke, but I performed it as if I was a great magician. So it was like an ironic kind of like. And you did it to music. To music. And did you speak?
哑剧演员。是啊。什么？我愿意付出任何代价去看那个。任何代价。我用手变魔术。哦，天哪。它们并不是真正的魔术。那是个笑话，但我表演得好像我是一个伟大的魔术师。所以这是一种讽刺，就像是……而且你是伴着音乐做的。伴着音乐。你说话吗？
No. No, there was no speaking. Oh, lady. Yeah. I need a photo. I need a video. I need something. Okay.
不。不，没有说话。哦，女士。是啊。我需要一张照片。我需要一段视频。我需要点什么。好的。
I'll do the show for you sometime. This was my only foray into. What? Promise me, we will have wine together and you will do this for me. I'll do it. I still have my tuxedo and the music. Yeah, I still have it. You wore a tuxedo.
我以后会为你表演的。这是我唯一的一次尝试。什么？答应我，我们会一起喝红酒，你会为我表演这个。我会的。我还有我的燕尾服和音乐。是啊，我还有。你穿燕尾服。
Yes, I was a fancy magician. I wore a coat and tails. Oh, my God. Yeah. So, listen, my point is, I don't know how to come back from that. I don't know. It's going to take me a beat. Okay, well, listen, what I'm saying in relation to Scrantonicity to,
是的，我是一个时髦的魔术师。我穿了一件燕尾服。哦，天哪。是啊。所以，听着，我的意思是，我不知道该怎么从那件事里走出来。我不知道。我需要一点时间。好的，好吧，听着，关于“Scrantonicity 2”，我想说的是，
is in my experience performing this show, the number of people you brought in who bought a ticket to, like, the comedy show that night, that determined your placement in the show. So, like, if no one came, you'd be at the end of the night and you'd be performing to a room of, like, three people. Right. So, you know, this is why Kevin needs people to come, I think,
根据我表演这个节目的经验，你带来的买了那天晚上喜剧表演门票的人数，决定了你在节目中的出场顺序。所以，如果没人来，你就会在深夜表演，面对的观众只有三个人。对。所以，你知道，这就是为什么我认为凯文需要人们来，
because, well, he has the applause meter. I don't know. This is gone very off topic, everyone. I'm sorry. I, I, my heart is so full. I am, I am, this is a gift. I was not expecting today. I have all of these visuals in my head of you in a tuxedo,
因为，嗯，他有掌声测量仪。我不知道。大家，这话题跑得太偏了。我很抱歉。我，我，我的心太满了。我，我，这是一个礼物。我今天没预料到。我的脑海里全是你在喜剧俱乐部穿着燕尾服，
miming magic tricks at a comedy club. It's, um, yeah. Oh, it's, it's just 100% awesome. Okay. Well, now Michael. Also says he cannot go to Kevin's show. And Jim and Pam, they're like, oh, light bulb. This is when we tell him we should have dinner because they know he's not available.
表演哑剧魔术的画面。这，嗯，是啊。哦，这简直是100%的棒。好的。好吧，现在迈克尔也说他不能去凯文的演出。吉姆和帕姆，他们就像是，哦，灵光一闪。这就是我们告诉他我们应该一起吃晚饭的时候，因为他们知道他没空。
So sneaky, you two. Yes. Also, very sweet to realize that if Michael was available, he probably would go to Kevin's show because that's Michael, right? Of course. He goes to everything. Yeah. And also, maybe now it's an opportunity to get away from Jan. Yeah.
你们俩真狡猾。是的。意识到如果迈克尔有空，他可能会去凯文的演出，因为那就是迈克尔，对吧？当然。他什么都去。是啊。而且，也许现在是一个远离简的机会。是啊。
There's a whole deleted scene runner where he's just avoiding having to talk to her. Well, the reason that Michael can't go to this show or have dinner with Jim and Pam is because he has taken a second job as a telemarketer to pay his bills. And Paul does this very beautiful thing, I think, in his directing, as Michael's riding the bus, getting off the bus stop, walking into this building, you hear this dialogue. And it says, I'm sorry, Mr. O'Brien. I didn't mean to interrupt your dinner. I just have a very exciting offer. My records indicate that you have expressed interest in losing some weight. Well, what if I told you that I have a pill that will make you 50 pounds lighter in five minutes?
有一个完整的删减场景，他只是在避免和她说话。嗯，迈克尔不能去参加这个演出或和吉姆与帕姆共进晚餐的原因是，他为了支付账单，找了一份电话推销员的兼职。保罗在导演时做了一件非常美妙的事情，我认为，当迈克尔坐公交车、下车、走进这栋大楼时，你听到了这段对话。它说，对不起，奥布莱恩先生。我不是故意打断您的晚餐。我只是有一个非常令人兴奋的提议。我的记录显示您曾表示有兴趣减肥。那么，如果我告诉您，我有一种药丸可以让您在五分钟内轻50磅呢？
How does that sound? Amazing, right? And it's this wonderful way that we now, as an audience, know exactly what's happening. Yeah. Before we even see what's in the building. I thought it was so brilliant. Yeah. Yeah, that's some beautiful writing. Well, now also, Pam and Jim are arriving to Shrewt Farms. Yeah, Pam is clearly in super pun mode. She's calling it the Beats Motel, the Embassy Beats, the Radish Inn. She's in rare form.
听起来怎么样？太棒了，对吧？这是一种美妙的方式，让我们作为观众确切地知道发生了什么。是啊。在我们看到大楼里有什么之前。我觉得这太聪明了。是啊。是啊，那是一些优美的剧本。好吧，现在帕姆和吉姆也到达了施鲁特农场。是啊，帕姆显然处于超级双关语模式。她管它叫“甜菜汽车旅馆”、“大使甜菜”、“萝卜旅馆”。她状态极佳。
Well, this scene of Jim and Pam driving up to Shrewd Farms, this is the scene where John turned on the seat warmer. On my side of the car, we talked about it when he came on office ladies. Yes, he called it his Clooney joke, right? Yes, yes. I just kept getting so hot. I was like, John, I am so hot. Are you hot? He's like, no, I don't know what you're talking about.
嗯，吉姆和帕姆开车去施鲁特农场的这一幕，就是约翰打开座椅加热器的那一幕。在我那一侧的车里，当他上《办公室女士》节目时我们谈过。是的，他称之为他的“克鲁尼笑话”，对吧？是的，是的。我一直觉得太热了。我说，约翰，我太热了。你热吗？他说，不，我不知道你在说什么。
And he had turned on my seat warmer. Oh, my gosh. I love that. Because you couldn't have the AC on in the car. That was the thing because it messed with the sound. Right. So we had to have, you know, the car is getting warm. It was warm in the day.
他打开了我的座椅加热器。哦，天哪。我喜欢这个。因为车里不能开空调。就是因为那个，因为它会干扰声音。对。所以我们不得不，你知道，车里越来越热。那天很热。
And then on top of it, your seat is heating up. That's so great. Well, I want you guys to know right as they turn down the road to go to Shrewp Farms, when this scene is happening, there's a great shot of the Shrewp Farms mailbox. And the many times that I filmed there with Rain, one time I took my camera and I took all of these kind of artsy photos. And I took an artsy photo of the mailbox. But I love it. I actually think it would be really cool. like I should like blow it up like canvas size. I think it looks really cool.
再加上，你的座位还在加热。这太棒了。好吧，我想让你们知道，就在他们转弯去施鲁特农场时，当这一幕发生时，有一个施鲁特农场邮箱的精彩镜头。我和雷恩在那里拍摄了很多次，有一次我拿着相机，拍了所有这些艺术感十足的照片。我拍了一张邮箱的艺术照。但我喜欢它。我其实觉得如果我把它放大到画布大小会很酷。我觉得它看起来真的很酷。
We had a fan question about this scene of Jim and Pam arriving at Shrewt Farms from Amaya Norsey. She said at around eight minutes, 21 seconds, Moes appears behind their car and starts running alongside them. How was that decided? Because it's really funny and it creates Moses' personality. I reached out to Paul. I would love to hear what he says. Well, first of all, he came up with the idea for Moes running alongside the car while in a cafe in Russia. I love how... It's like his inspiration is in Russia. It's hilarious. I love how he's always in these like foreign countries when he is writing these scripts and having his good ideas.
我们收到了一个关于吉姆和帕姆到达施鲁特农场这一幕的粉丝提问，来自阿玛亚·诺西。她说在大约8分21秒，莫斯出现在他们的车后，开始跟着他们跑。这是怎么决定的？因为它真的很有趣，而且塑造了莫斯的个性。我联系了保罗。我很想听听他怎么说。嗯，首先，他在俄罗斯的一家咖啡馆里想出了莫斯跟着车跑的主意。我喜欢……他的灵感竟然是在俄罗斯。这太搞笑了。我喜欢他写这些剧本并产生好点子时，总是身处这些外国。
But he said he started laughing out loud at the idea of Moes running alongside the car, quote, like a dog. And that's what he wrote in the script. So that moment was totally scripted that Moes would run alongside the car like a puppy dog to greet the new visitors. And it was written by an American tourist in Russia laughing out loud by himself
但他说是他想到莫斯跟着车跑的主意时大笑起来，引用他的话，“像条狗一样”。这就是他在剧本里写的。所以那一刻完全是剧本安排的，莫斯会像小狗一样跟着车跑来迎接新访客。而这剧本是一个美国游客在俄罗斯独自大笑时写的。
to no one. In a cafe. Well, I wanted to commend Mike Scher on how fast he is. So fast. Dang! And you guys, we filmed that several times. We filmed that arrival because we had to film it with a cameraman inside the car, but then we
在咖啡馆里。好吧，我想表扬迈克·舒尔，他跑得真快。太快了！该死！伙计们，我们拍了好几次。我们拍摄了那次到达，因为我们必须让摄影师在车里拍，但后来我们
also have a shot of us driving where we took the cameraman out of the car and they just shot John and I. So, I mean, Mike ran a lot that day. Well, I think Mike was put through the ringer in this episode. There is a whole deleted scene where he is jumping on a kind of busted trampoline for Pam and Jim and doing all of these things, helicopter, look over here. and he's doing, like, constantly, he was on that trampoline doing tons of stuff. He must have been so sore after this day.
也有一个我们开车的镜头，我们把摄影师从车里拿出来，他们只是拍了约翰和我。所以，我的意思是，迈克那天跑了很多。嗯，我觉得迈克在这一集里被折磨得够呛。有一个完整的删减场景，他为了帕姆和吉姆在一种破旧的蹦床上跳，做所有这些动作，直升机，看这里。他一直在做，他一直在那个蹦床上做各种动作。这一天之后他一定很酸痛。
And hot and tired. Yeah. Well, lady, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're going to meet Nick Figaro, manager to the stars, and also take a look inside Shrewt farms. I like it. All right. I'm going to take a break and I will not be on a yacht, but I might be doing some magic. So now we are back.
而且又热又累。是啊。好吧，女士，我们休息一下好吗？回来后，我们将见到明星经纪人尼克·菲格罗，并看看施鲁特农场的内部。我喜欢。好的。我要休息一下，我不会在游艇上，但我可能会变点魔术。现在我们回来了。
Michael is in his cubicle at the telemarketing company, and his boss, Nick Figuero, notices the camera crew. He walks over, he's like, what's happening here? Michael's like, it's okay, they're with me. And then he has this very funny speech where he's like, we're a legitimate operation. Like, clearly they're not. Because he literally not.
迈克尔在电话推销公司的隔间里，他的老板尼克·菲格罗注意到了摄像组。他走过来，说，这里发生了什么？迈克尔说，没关系，他们和我一起的。然后他发表了一段非常有趣的演讲，他说，我们是一个合法的经营机构。就像，显然他们不是。因为他字面上就不是。
He has to, like, point that out. Well, the actor who plays Nick Figuero is Alan Wasserman, and here are some other roles that he has played. He's done a ton of television shows, but I also found it interesting that he played the gym teacher in the Tom Hanks movie Big and the job interviewer in the Tom Cruise movie Cocktails. Oh, wow. Oh, those are two great movies. Well, my favorite thing is when he does what Michael always does. He calls a conference room meeting. Five minutes.
他不得不指出这一点。嗯，扮演尼克·菲格罗的演员是艾伦·沃瑟曼，以下是他扮演过的一些其他角色。他演过很多电视剧，但我还发现有趣的是，他在汤姆·汉克斯的电影《飞越未来》中扮演了体育老师，在汤姆·克鲁斯的电影《鸡尾酒》中扮演了面试官。哦，哇。哦，那是两部很棒的电影。好吧，我最喜欢的是他做迈克尔总是做的事情。他召集会议室开会。五分钟。
And Mike's like, oh, these things are useless. Yes. And then in this conference room meeting, when Nick Figaro is trying to explain how to make a sale, Michael is just making jokes under his breath. Yes. And his coworkers love him. He's the gym of the telemarketing office. He is.
迈克说，哦，这些东西都没用。是的。然后在这次会议室会议中，当尼克·菲格罗试图解释如何达成销售时，迈克尔只是在低声开玩笑。是的。他的同事们很喜欢他。他是电话推销办公室的吉姆。他是。
and they just want him to hang out with him. They're constantly inviting him to go hang out. There's deleted scenes where they are just, they hang on his every word. Well, I got very interested in this scene at 10 minutes, 25 seconds. There is a couple. Did you see them? The woman is pregnant, very pregnant, and this man, they're all over each other, very lovey-dovey, right? And they are in all the,
他们只是想和他待在一起。他们不断邀请他出去玩。有删减场景，他们只是挂在他的每一句话上。嗯，我对10分25秒的这一幕非常感兴趣。有一对情侣。你看到了吗？那个女人怀孕了，非常显怀，而这个男人，他们黏在一起，非常恩爱，对吧？而且他们在所有
other deleted scenes too. They're always sort of like in some kind of embrace. I became a little bit obsessed with them. I was like, is this woman really pregnant? Where they hired as a couple? What is the story here? So I did a bit of a deep dive. Okay. I found out that the woman is an actress named Ann Maddox. And then I found out that Ann Maddox is our producer Cody's friend. What? They're friends on Instagram. I deep dived. I was like, how can I get an end with this woman, Anne? So Cody reached out to her friend and she answered all my questions. Oh, give me all of it. I want it. Give it to me. Okay. Here's how it went down. Anne was a performer at UCB and she said that there was a request for female performers to come in for a role in the office. She was not pregnant in real life,
其他删减场景里也都在。他们总是处于某种拥抱中。我有点迷上他们了。我在想，这个女人真的怀孕了吗？他们是作为情侣被雇佣的吗？这里有什么故事？所以我做了一次深入挖掘。好的。我发现那个女人是一位名叫安·马多克斯的女演员。然后我发现安·马多克斯是我们制片人科迪的朋友。什么？他们在Instagram上是朋友。我深入挖掘。我在想，我怎么能和这个女人安搭上线？所以科迪联系了她的朋友，她回答了我所有的问题。哦，把所有细节都给我。我想要。给我。好的。事情是这样的。安是UCB的一名表演者，她说当时有一个请求，要求女性表演者来参加《办公室》的一个角色试镜。她在现实生活中并没有怀孕，
but the role was for a young pregnant woman working nights alongside her baby dad. and it was scripted that this couple would be lovey-dovey and affectionate constantly. So she auditioned, she got the role, and then she got paired with this other actor randomly. But here's what she said. She said, I remember that one of the cameramen did not know that the cuddling was in the script. And he kept saying to me and my co-star, you guys are so affectionate. And then he turned to the other camera operator and said, they've been like this all day. It's so funny. And she was like, no, it was scripted. It was
但这个角色是一个年轻的孕妇，晚上和她的孩子爸爸一起工作。剧本设定这对情侣会一直恩爱和亲昵。所以她试镜了，她得到了这个角色，然后她被随机分配给了这个男演员。但这是她说的。她说，我记得其中一个摄影师不知道拥抱是剧本要求的。他一直对我和我的搭档说，你们俩太亲热了。然后他转向另一个摄像师说，他们整天都这样。这太搞笑了。她说，不，这是剧本要求的。这是
scripted. She also remembered that they shot in the LA Times building. She remembered that we had amazing food and that the cast and crew were so nice. But she said what's so heartwarming to her about that memory is just how everyone on set treated her like a friend. The crew, the cast, She said she just had the best time of her life and she'll cherish the experience forever. It was so nice. I love that. I also love what a very specific thing that Paul did. Paul was so thoughtful in filling out the world at the telemarketing company that he wrote in the script
剧本要求的。她还记得他们是在《洛杉矶时报》大楼拍摄的。她记得我们有很棒的食物，演员和工作人员都很好。但她说，关于那个记忆，最让她感到温暖的是片场里的每个人都像朋友一样对待她。工作人员，演员，她说她度过了人生中最美好的时光，她将永远珍惜这段经历。这太好了。我喜欢。我也喜欢保罗做的一件非常具体的事情。保罗在填充电话推销公司的世界观时非常体贴，他在剧本里写道
that would be a young pregnant woman and her baby daddy. And that was so specific. Yeah. I love that we often did that on the show where even minor characters who show show up for just one episode, they have a story. That's so great. I just love it. Yeah. And there were a lot of deleted scenes. There's a lot of scenes you don't see of this couple and of all these people interacting with Michael. Yes, this couple loved Michael. They invited him out to dinner. There's a deleted scene with it. And once again, Jenna, I feel like our set decorators were having fun because there's
那会是一个年轻的孕妇和她的孩子爸爸。这太具体了。是啊。我喜欢我们经常在剧里这样做，即使是只出现一集的次要角色，他们也有故事。这太棒了。我就是喜欢。是啊。而且有很多删减场景。有很多你没看到的关于这对情侣以及所有这些人与迈克尔互动的场景。是的，这对情侣很喜欢迈克尔。他们邀请他出去吃晚饭。有一个删减场景。再一次，珍娜，我觉得我们的片场装饰师玩得很开心，因为有
all of these cartoon clippings. So many. So many. And then there's a white piece of paper that says constant, continuous Roger demands. Don't know. Don't know. Very strange. I saw it too. I don't know what it means. Well, Alan Wasserman as Nick Vigero was fantastic.
所有这些卡通剪报。太多了。太多了。然后有一张白纸，上面写着“持续，连续，罗杰要求”。不知道。不知道。非常奇怪。我也看到了。我不知道那是什么意思。好吧，艾伦·沃瑟曼饰演的尼克·菲格罗太棒了。
I thought he was perfect. I loved his whole make the call, say the lines, make the sale. He was just like, I believed him 100% that he was this guy. Well, you know, Ange, in addition to being a silent magician, I always, also worked as a telemarketer. And I can tell you that Ellen Wasserman's performance is right on. He's like every boss I ever had in my telemarketing days. Well, you know, I worked at 1-800 dentist as an operator and I would constantly get in trouble for not saying line number 13 correctly. Oh, yeah. The scripts are very specific. Like they've been researched. They've been put through
我觉得他很完美。我喜欢他整个“打个电话，说台词，达成销售”的风格。他就像是，我100%相信他就是这个人。好吧，你知道，安吉，除了做一个沉默的魔术师，我也一直做过电话推销员。我可以告诉你，艾伦·沃瑟曼的表演非常到位。他就像我电话推销日子里遇到的每一个老板。好吧，你知道，我在1-800牙医那里做过接线员，我经常因为没有正确说出第13行台词而惹麻烦。哦，是的。剧本非常具体。就像它们经过研究。它们经过了
focus groups. My job was to call people and get them to subscribe to the St. Louis Post Dispatch newspaper. And we had a big deal on the Sunday paper. And I was supposed to push the Sunday paper. Well, line 13, if I remember, was something about like you would say what their ailment was and tell them the dentist you were going to send them to. And it was so stilted. And I remember I would say like, you know what? It sounds like to me you might need a root canal. I mean, that kind of pain like that sounds like an abscess and literally my manager would come in waving his arms and you'd be like you are not a dental professional you cannot diagnose yeah have to say this line exactly well let me help you with that toothache by finding a dentist for you in your area like i can't
焦点小组测试。我的工作是打电话给人们，让他们订阅《圣路易斯邮报》。我们对周日版报纸有一个大优惠。我应该推销周日版报纸。嗯，第13行，如果我没记错的话，是关于你要说出他们的病痛，并告诉他们你要把他们送到哪位牙医那里。这太生硬了。我记得我会说，你知道吗？听起来你可能需要做根管治疗。我的意思是，那种疼痛听起来像是脓肿，我的经理真的会走进来挥舞着手臂说，你不是牙科专业人士，你不能诊断。是啊，必须完全按照这行台词说。好吧，让我通过为你寻找你所在地区的牙医来帮你解决牙痛，就像我不能
say sounds like a root canal to me what are you doing lady so i would get in trouble well jennah should we get to shrewp farms. Let's go to shrewd farms. Jim and Pam are sitting on a couch in what looks like a sort of reception slash lobby area. And Dwight is explaining that there are three types of rooms available. He's checking them in. They can stay in America, irrigation, or nighttime. Pam immediately says irrigation. I mean, without thought, she was so positive. Yeah. I'm curious about nighttime, but I think I would have also chosen irrigation. And by the way, it doesn't disappoint. When Dwight shows them to their room, the irrigation room has a lot of pipes hanging from the walls.
说“听起来像根管治疗”，你在做什么，女士？所以我总是惹麻烦。好吧，珍娜，我们去施鲁特农场吧。去施鲁特农场吧。吉姆和帕姆坐在沙发上，看起来像是一个接待/大厅区域。德怀特正在解释有三种房间可供选择。他正在为他们办理入住。他们可以住在“美国”、“灌溉”或“夜间”。帕姆立即说“灌溉”。我的意思是，不假思索，她非常肯定。是啊。我对“夜间”很好奇，但我想我也会选择“灌溉”。顺便说一句，它没有让人失望。当德怀特带他们去房间时，灌溉房的墙上挂着很多管子。
It's a wonderful design. Pipes with no purpose, though. No, no, no. It's decor. They're decorative, yeah. Decorative pipes. Yes. And two twin beds.
这是一个很棒的设计。不过是没用的管子。不，不，不。那是装饰。它们是装饰性的，是的。装饰管。是的。还有两张单人床。
Mm-hmm. Yeah. Now, I believe, I don't know if there's a deleted scene of it, but there was a scene that we shot where you see that Jim and Pam have pushed the two beds together. In the morning, you see into the room and Jim and Pam have actually made it one bed. Yes. And I was like, wait, is there two beds or one bed? And then I realized what they had done. Yes.
嗯哼。是啊。现在，我相信，我不知道有没有删减场景，但我们拍过一个场景，你看到吉姆和帕姆把两张床推到了一起。早上，你看到房间里，吉姆和帕姆实际上把它变成了一张床。是的。我当时想，等等，是两张床还是一张床？然后我意识到他们做了什么。是的。
Yes. But I really like this moment on the two beds with Jim and Pam. when Jim says one and six. And Pam's like, what? And he's like, oh, I'm sorry. I thought you asked me, what are our chances of being murdered tonight? Yeah.
是的。但我真的很喜欢吉姆和帕姆在两张床上的这一刻。当吉姆说“一和六”。帕姆说，什么？他说，哦，对不起。我以为你在问我，我们今晚被谋杀的几率是多少？是啊。
And Jim has this really sweet talking head where he says he had this whole vision of what it would be like to have a weekend away with Pam. What our first trip away would be like? It's so romantic, really, and sweet. And he said it definitely would not have been, you know, wine made out of beats.
吉姆有一个非常甜蜜的采访镜头，他说他曾对和帕姆一起度过的周末有过整个愿景。我们第一次出游会是什么样子？这真的很浪漫，很甜蜜。他说绝对不会是，你知道，用甜菜酿的酒。
Probably not with Dwight and definitely not with so much manure. Yeah, maybe some manure. But less, less manure. Yeah, and we filmed all of these little moments that went under this talking head. So you see Dwight mashing up beats to make beet wine and then you see us out in the field helping to shovel this manure. And then Moes gets into a manure like a snowball fight with Dwight. but he's throwing manure. Mm-hmm.
可能不会和德怀特在一起，也绝对不会有这么多粪肥。是啊，也许会有一些粪肥。但少一点，少一点粪肥。是啊，我们拍摄了所有这些出现在这个采访镜头下的小瞬间。所以你看到德怀特捣碎甜菜来酿甜菜酒，然后你看到我们在田野里帮忙铲这些粪肥。然后莫斯和德怀特打了一场粪肥雪仗。但他扔的是粪肥。嗯哼。
And I remember shooting all of that. We had a fan question from Matthew K. When Dwight and Pam are shoveling manure, was it real? And was the moment when Moe starts throwing manure at Dwight scripted, or was that just Mike Scher messing with rain? Okay, it was not real manure. Right. It was not.
我记得拍摄所有这些。我们收到了马修·K的一个粉丝提问。当德怀特和帕姆铲粪肥时，那是真的吗？莫斯开始向德怀特扔粪肥的那一刻是剧本写的，还是迈克·舒尔在捉弄雷恩？好的，那不是真的粪肥。对。不是。
Of course not. Yeah. No. Faking manure. Put it on our list. Yes. And it was scripted, this idea. this little snowball fight of manure.
当然不是。是啊。不。假粪肥。把它写进我们的清单。是的。这个主意是剧本写的。这个小小的粪肥雪仗。
That was in the script. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. So, yeah, faky poo. I wonder what it was made of. It was just like dirt and there was some, you know, hay inside of it and stuff. It was just like a muddy kind of mess. Right.
那在剧本里。是啊，是啊。所以，是啊，假便便。我不知道它是用什么做的。它就像泥土，里面有一些干草之类的东西。它就像一种泥泞的混乱。对。
So they probably could really pelt each other. It probably could hurt. Yes. Lady, I want to point something out about this episode. And this scene here when we're shoveling the manure is really your best. look at it. Here is my thing. What the F am I wearing? I know. Did you look at my outfit in this episode? What is it? My pants look waterproof. Well, also they don't fit. They're too long. They're all baggy. They like go over your shoes. They look like a pair of very like hip-hugger
所以他们可能真的能互相投掷。这可能会疼。是的。女士，我想指出关于这一集的一件事。这一幕我们铲粪肥的时候，真的是你最好看的时候。这是我的看法。我到底穿了什么？我知道。你看了我在这一集里的装扮吗？那是什么？我的裤子看起来防水。嗯，而且它们不合身。它们太长了。它们很宽松。它们盖过了你的鞋子。它们看起来像是一条非常像嘻哈风格的
waterproof cargo pants. I don't know. And a very, very ill-fitted sweater. I know. I know. Oh, and also, like, did we not alter anything? Did Pam not want to look cute on her first night away with Jim? Pam. Well, I think you look very cute later in your gray tank top, though. You look very cute. I do look really cute in my great tank top. You do. When it's time for bed.
防水工装裤。我不知道。还有一件非常、非常不合身的毛衣。我知道。我知道。哦，还有，我们是不是什么都没改？帕姆不想在她和吉姆第一次在外过夜时看起来可爱一点吗？帕姆。嗯，我觉得你后来穿灰色背心时看起来很可爱。你看起来很可爱。我穿灰色背心时确实看起来很可爱。你确实。当该睡觉的时候。
I was like, oh, Jenna looks so cute. But this outfit is a hot mess. It really, really is. Well, you mentioned my little tank top, Angela. and first of all, I don't sleep in clothes like that. I sleep completely dressed. Lee calls it my sleeping suit. He's like, it's amazing how you've covered up all of your skin from your neck down to your wrists, down to your ankles.
我当时想，哦，珍娜看起来真可爱。但这套衣服简直是一团糟。它真的，真的是。嗯，你提到了我的小背心，安吉拉。首先，我睡觉不穿那样的衣服。我睡觉时穿得严严实实。李称之为我的“睡眠服”。他说，真神奇，你竟然把从脖子到手腕，再到脚踝的所有皮肤都遮住了。
Because I get cold at night, we've discussed. But Pam is in the cutest little tank top and pajama pants. It was freezing in that building. But it's a really cute moment. because Dwight is reading them a bedtime story. He's reading them Harry Potter. And Jim and Pam are snuggling and Moses
因为我晚上怕冷，我们讨论过。但帕姆穿着最可爱的小背心和睡裤。那栋楼里冷极了。但这真的是一个很可爱的时刻。因为德怀特在给他们读睡前故事。他在给他们读《哈利·波特》。吉姆和帕姆在依偎着，莫斯在
listening. It's sweet and awkward all at the same time. Well, we had a fan question. A lot of fan questions about the Harry Potter book. Was he really reading? Yada yada. Well, Emma H has come to our rescue
听着。这既甜蜜又尴尬。嗯，我们收到了一个粉丝提问。很多关于《哈利·波特》书的粉丝提问。他真的在读吗？等等等等。嗯，艾玛·H来救场了
and she says, I am currently rereading the Harry Potter series and I just happened to come across the page that Dwight reads to Jim and Pam. It is page 85 from the Deathly Hollow's book. It is the scene when Voldemar is interrogating Olavander and the Wandmaker. Now, I'm sorry if I stumbled through that,
她说，我目前正在重读《哈利·波特》系列，我刚好翻到了德怀特读给吉姆和帕姆听的那一页。那是《死亡圣器》书中的第85页。那是伏地魔审问奥利凡德和魔杖制造者的场景。现在，如果我读得磕磕绊绊，我很抱歉，
but I am not familiar with this series. This falls into the Star Wars area for me. Okay, Jenna. Okay. Well, did I say those names right, Voldemort? Voldemort. Isn't that the person you're not supposed to say? Yes, exactly.
但我对这个系列不熟悉。这对我来说属于《星球大战》的范畴。好的，珍娜。好的。嗯，我那些名字读对了吗，伏地魔？伏地魔。那不是你不应该说出名字的那个人吗？是的，完全正确。
and olivander well that is fantastic i love to know where that is in the book so thanks for that catch emma and before we move away from this lovely harry potter reading jenna here's my thing about pam's outfit what pam is doing what you do at the beginning of a relationship where you're still trying to look cute at bedtime that will pass maybe that's what she really sleeps in I need to know this, actually. Whenever I watch TV shows or movies and women are in the morning, they're getting coffee in the morning or they're going to bed at night, they're always dressed in these like little pajamas with the little shorts and the little tank tops or something. I don't know. Sometimes women are wearing like, what are those things?
还有奥利凡德。好吧，那太棒了，我很高兴知道它在书里的位置，所以谢谢你的发现，艾玛。在我们离开这段可爱的《哈利·波特》阅读之前，珍娜，这是我对帕姆装扮的看法。帕姆正在做你在一段关系的开始时会做的事，那时你还在试图在睡前看起来很可爱，那会过去的。也许那就是她真正睡觉时穿的。我其实需要知道这个。每当我看电视节目或电影，女人们在早上，她们早上在喝咖啡，或者晚上睡觉时，她们总是穿着那种带有小短裤和小背心之类的睡衣。我不知道。有时女人们穿着像，那些东西是什么？
like silken shift dress things to bed. Laundre? Laundere? Not full lingerie, but like a, you know, what are they called? They're like silk or satin. What are they called? I don't know, but I used to have little tank top and short combos. I would get them at Target, like pajamas.
像丝绸睡裙之类的东西睡觉。吊带裙？吊带裙？不是全套内衣，而是像，你知道，它们叫什么？它们是丝绸或缎子的。它们叫什么？我不知道，但我以前有小背心和短裤套装。我会在塔吉特买它们，就像睡衣一样。
And in the summer, I would sleep in shorts. I mean, because you know, I'm always going to have my place nice and warm. Sam just wrote, a slip? Yeah, like a slip dress thing. Yes, like a silky, slippy dress pajama thing. Who sleeps in that? Anyone out there, literally any woman listening, have you ever slept in one of those
在夏天，我会穿短裤睡觉。因为你知道，我总是要把我的地方弄得暖暖和和的。萨姆刚写道，吊带裙？是啊，就像吊带裙之类的东西。是的，就像丝绸的、滑溜溜的睡裙。谁穿那个睡觉？外面有任何人，真的任何听节目的女性，你们有没有穿过那种
when you weren't trying to impress a man? Oh, yeah. Like, this is what I love to sleep in. This is my go-to. I love to sleep in a silk slip. Yeah. Neglishe? A negligee.
当你不是为了给男人留下深刻印象的时候？哦，是的。就像，这是我喜欢穿的睡衣。这是我的首选。我喜欢穿丝绸吊带裙睡觉。是啊。睡袍？睡袍。
That's it. A negligee. Who sleeps in a negligee for reals? Well, there was a time in my life. I would have slept in a tank top in shorts. But now I live with a mountain man who freezes me out. And I'm sorry, those days are gone. I'm fully, I'm in my sleep suit, Jenna.
就是那个。睡袍。真的有人穿睡袍睡觉吗？嗯，我生命中有一段时间。我会穿背心和短裤睡觉。但现在我和一个把我冻坏的山里人住在一起。我很抱歉，那些日子一去不复返了。我完全，我穿着我的睡眠服，珍娜。
All right. Well, so everybody is winding down for the night at Shrewt Farms. Michael is still at work. He's still telemarketing. But it's time for his dinner break. Yes, it's dinner time. And his cubicle mate right next to him is Vickram. Vikram is played by Ranjit Chaudhry.
好的。好吧，所以每个人都在施鲁特农场准备休息了。迈克尔还在工作。他还在做电话推销。但现在是他的晚餐时间。是的，是晚餐时间。他隔壁的同事是维克拉姆。维克拉姆由兰吉特·乔杜里饰演。
He does such a phenomenal job. I thought it was perfect. Everything he said as an actor, he just sort of threw it away, you know? And I just thought he was a phenomenal actor, and I just thought he crushed all of his scenes. It was so believable. Vickram is eating mixed masala and eggplant and rice. His dinner looks amazing, and it looks like it was prepared with love and all these little nice containers. And Michael is having a vanilla crisp bar.
他做得太出色了。我觉得很完美。他作为演员说的每一句话，他都随口说出来，你知道吗？我只是觉得他是一位了不起的演员，我觉得他演活了他所有的场景。这太可信了。维克拉姆正在吃混合马萨拉、茄子和米饭。他的晚餐看起来很棒，看起来是用爱和所有这些漂亮的小容器准备的。而迈克尔正在吃一根香草脆棒。
Yes. which is a real thing. It's a power bar. Yeah. Yeah. But what you see is that, you know, well, Jan doesn't know where Michael is, but she certainly hasn't sent him to work with a lovely meal, the way Vickram's partner clearly has. Ranji, very sadly, he passed away in April of last year. He was so great to work with. And guys, he's going to come back for another episode. You might remember he is part of Michael's dream team when Michael starts the Michael Scott Paper Company. So, I got to work with him when he came back. And I got a few facts on him because I just thought he was so wonderful.
是的，那确实是个东西。那是个能量棒。没错。没错。但你看到的是，你知道，好吧，简不知道迈克尔在哪里，但她肯定没有像维克拉姆的搭档那样，给迈克尔准备一顿可口的饭菜。兰吉，非常遗憾，他在去年四月去世了。和他一起工作真是太棒了。伙计们，他还会回来参加另一集。你们可能记得他是迈克尔创办迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司时“梦之队”的一员。所以，当他回来时，我有机会和他一起工作。我收集了一些关于他的事实，因为我觉得他太棒了。
You know, his mother was a theater teacher and an actress. His stepfather was a theater director. And he just, he worked his whole life as an actor and a writer. And he just had this very long career as an artist and comes from a long line of artists. So he's just amazing. I loved watching him in his scene. I agree. Well, after they have dinner, Michael is sort of holding court with the other telemarketers. They love him. He's talking about Die Hard and how Die Hard won the original.
你知道，他的母亲是戏剧老师和演员。他的继父是戏剧导演。他一生都以演员和作家的身份工作。他作为艺术家有着非常漫长的职业生涯，并且出身于一个艺术家世家。所以他真的很了不起。我喜欢看他演的戏。我同意。好吧，吃完晚饭后，迈克尔和电话推销员们在一起，他们很喜欢他。他在谈论《虎胆龙威》以及《虎胆龙威》是如何获得最初的...
John McLean was just this normal guy. You know, he's just a New York City cop and then he gets his feet cut and gets beat up. Jenna, I had just watched Die Hard over the holidays. We were picking Christmas movies and it's a kind of a great Christmas movie. It's one of my favorite Christmas movies. And right out of the gate, Josh turns to me and goes, I would have put my shoes on. The minute I heard gunfire, I would have put my shoes on. This was a really hard thing for Josh to get past that this guy had no shoes on for like the whole movie. And also, also he takes the shoes off this enormously tall Nordic guy, right? He's just died. Massive dude. And he's like, shoes are too small. And we're like, okay, we're going to call BS on that. There's no way
约翰·麦克莱恩只是个普通人。你知道，他只是个纽约警察，然后他的脚被割伤了，还被打了一顿。珍娜，我刚在假期看了《虎胆龙威》。我们在选圣诞电影，它算是一部很棒的圣诞电影。这是我最喜欢的圣诞电影之一。刚开始，乔什就转过头对我说，我会穿上鞋子的。我一听到枪声，我就会穿上鞋子。这对乔什来说真的很难接受，这家伙整部电影几乎都没穿鞋。而且，他还脱掉了一个身材极其高大的北欧人的鞋子，对吧？那人刚死。块头很大。他说，鞋子太小了。我们当时想，好吧，我们要说这是胡扯。根本不可能
that dude's feet are smaller than yours, Bruce Willis. What's happening? Yeah. Well, you know, and then the thing happens in this movie that's real hard for me, where he gets the piece of glass and his foot and he does not take care of that properly. He just does not. No. But it's such a...
那家伙的脚比你的还小，布鲁斯·威利斯。怎么回事？是的。好吧，你知道，电影里发生了一件让我很难受的事，他脚上扎了块玻璃，但他没有好好处理。他根本没处理。不。但这真是...
I mean, I know he doesn't have a lot of options, but that kind of stuff. It just, ooh. It gets you. Well, anyway, everyone is loving Michael's theory on Die Hard and the Die Hard series. And one of the co-workers is like, dude, you should review movies. They're like, yeah. And then Michael's like, actually, I'm writing a movie. Yeah, threat level midnight.
我是说，我知道他没多少选择，但那种事。真是，噢。让人受不了。好吧，不管怎样，每个人都喜欢迈克尔关于《虎胆龙威》和《虎胆龙威》系列的理论。其中一个同事说，伙计，你应该去影评。他们说，是啊。然后迈克尔说，其实，我正在写一部电影。是的，《威胁等级午夜》。
Yeah. And they're like, oh. Ooh. But I just think it's so incredibly charming that Michael is like, he's the cool dude. I know. He's the cool dude at this place. I know. Well, back at Shrewp Farms, Pam hears a very strange knocking noise.
是的。他们说，噢。噢。但我只是觉得迈克尔表现得像个酷哥，这真是太迷人了。我知道。他是这里最酷的家伙。我知道。好吧，回到施鲁特农场，帕姆听到了一种非常奇怪的敲击声。
she decides to investigate. And it's Moes in an outhouse, an outhouse, and the wind is blowing the door, whack, whack, whack. And Pam is like, what sentry is this? I know. Well, Paul told me this is one of his favorite shots from this episode because it's all one long tracking shot and they had to time it out.
她决定去调查一下。是摩斯在厕所里，一个户外厕所，风吹着门，啪、啪、啪。帕姆说，这是什么哨兵？我知道。好吧，保罗告诉我这是他在这集中最喜欢的镜头之一，因为它是一个长镜头，他们必须掌握好时间。
They had to, you know, rack focus from Pam out to the outhouse. And, oh, poor Mike Schur had to. just sit out there and just wait for us every time we would reset. I mean, again, he's like put through the ringer in this episode. You know it was cold out there? Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Now, I want to point out, in an earlier episode,
他们必须，你知道，从帕姆身上把焦点移到户外厕所。而且，噢，可怜的迈克·舒尔不得不每次我们重拍时都坐在外面等着。我是说，再说一次，他在这一集中真是受尽了折磨。你知道外面很冷吗？噢，是的。噢，是的。现在，我想指出，在之前的一集中，
when Dwight is telling us about Shrewp Farms, he says that there's only one bathroom and it's under the porch. Oh, nice catch. So I like to think that maybe when he decided to do the B&B, he upgraded to an outhouse. A proper outhouse. Yes, this is my backstory for the Shrew Farm's outhouse. So they figure out what that sound is. So now Jim and Pam are going to go back to bed.
当德怀特告诉我们关于施鲁特农场的事时，他说只有一个厕所，而且在门廊下面。噢，好发现。所以我喜欢认为也许当他决定开民宿时，他升级到了一个户外厕所。一个正经的户外厕所。是的，这就是我对施鲁特农场户外厕所的背景故事。所以他们弄清楚了那是什么声音。现在吉姆和帕姆要回去睡觉了。
But now there's like a wailing, like a moaning. Yes. I mean, it's like, what is that noise? And so Jim, it's like his turn. So he's going to check it out. Well, at 15 minutes, 40 seconds, he approaches a door. Did you notice the wooden plaque says private room? Yes.
但现在有一种哀号声，像呻吟声。是的。我是说，那是什么声音？所以轮到吉姆了。所以他要去看看。好吧，在15分40秒时，他走近一扇门。你注意到木牌上写着“私人房间”了吗？是的。
Right? Yes. And he goes in and Dwight is holding the chair of figurine and moaning, but very briefly, and I'm talking very briefly, at 15 minutes, 52 seconds, over Jim's shoulder, you can see a little bit of a poster and I zoomed in on this poster and the legs it looks like a rock and roll band and the legs of the pants are white with gray stripes like skin tight pants you can't really make out the face but I got obsessed with these pants and I started looking up every Motley crew poster I could find because I'm positive it's Montley Crew right it's Dwight okay it's got to be
对吧？是的。他走进去，德怀特正拿着那个椅子小雕像在呻吟，但非常短暂，我说的是非常短暂，在15分52秒时，在吉姆的肩膀上方，你可以看到一点海报，我放大了这张海报，腿看起来像是一个摇滚乐队，裤子的腿是白色带灰色条纹的，就像紧身裤，你看不清脸，但我对这些裤子着迷了，我开始搜索我能找到的每一张克鲁小丑乐队的海报，因为我肯定那是克鲁小丑乐队，对吧，那是德怀特，好吧，一定是
motley crew. I'm telling you it is. I found a photo of Tommy Lee in the same white skin-tight stripy pants. And there is no doubt in my mind that in the private room, the love sanctuary of Angela and Dwight, that there's a Motley crew poster. If you remember on their album, Decade of Decadence, 81, there's a song called Angela. It's going to come into play later. Sam, hit it. And when the storms, scream, Angela, Angela, I'll be there. Wow. Yeah, that poster of Montley Crew, you know what that means to Dwight. It's his lady.
克鲁小丑乐队。我告诉你就是。我找到了一张汤米·李穿着同样白色紧身条纹裤的照片。我毫不怀疑在私人房间里，安吉拉和德怀特的爱情圣地，有一张克鲁小丑乐队的海报。如果你记得他们的专辑《十年颓废》，81年，有一首歌叫《安吉拉》。它稍后会派上用场。萨姆，放出来。当风暴，尖叫，安吉拉，安吉拉，我会在这里。哇。是的，那张克鲁小丑乐队的海报，你知道那对德怀特意味着什么。那是他的女士。
It's his heavy metal. And fans that have watched the show all the way through. I don't want to do any spoilers. That song's going to come back in a big way later. Wow. Wow. Well, I'll tell you what I noticed in this scene. At 16 minutes, we have got a huge,
那是他的重金属。还有那些把剧集看完的粉丝们。我不想剧透。那首歌稍后会以一种重要的方式回归。哇。哇。好吧，我告诉你我在这场戏里注意到了什么。在16分钟时，我们有一个巨大的，
duh white from Jim. But then at the end of the scene, when he's leaving the room, he throws out a regular Dwight. No. We have a duh white and a Dwight in the same scene. He never said Dwight. He always said DeWite.
吉姆说的“德怀特”（Duh-white）。但后来在场景结束时，当他离开房间时，他抛出了一个正常的“德怀特”（Dwight）。不。我们在同一个场景里既有“德怀特”（Duh-white）又有“德怀特”（Dwight）。他从来不说“德怀特”（Dwight）。他总是说“德怀特”（DeWite）。
Is this the one time John says Dwight? Well, I listened to it several times. Oh, my gosh, because this is our job. You're listening to that over and over. Meanwhile, I'm Google searching, like, rock and roll band pants. Well, I think he says Dwight, like Dwight, but it's the closest thing to a Dwight we're going to get. Okay. Well, guys, before we finish up here, we've got one last scene.
这是约翰唯一一次说“德怀特”（Dwight）吗？好吧，我听了好几次。噢，天哪，因为这就是我们的工作。你一遍又一遍地听那个。与此同时，我在谷歌搜索，比如，摇滚乐队的裤子。好吧，我想他说的是“德怀特”（Dwight），就像“德怀特”（Dwight），但这已经是最接近我们能得到的“德怀特”（Dwight）了。好吧。好吧，伙计们，在我们结束之前，我们还有最后一个场景。
it's the end of Michael's work day and he's walking outside everyone's inviting him to come to the bar with him come on Michael we want to spend more time with you yeah but he can't yeah Jan has come to pick him up she gets out of the car and she says you drive I've had too much wine great glad you drove here yeah thought the same thing and then Michael's like how was yoga she's like I didn't go. And he's like, why? And she's like, I just didn't. Oh. Oh. So sad. The Jan spiral man. And she's going to take Michael down with her. Yeah. And then Vickram tells Michael, listen, man, you might be able to nab that bonus if you just work a little harder. Vickram gives a, you know, a little pep talk there at the end. He's like, just stick to the script. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, Michael. Well, I love this.
那是迈克尔工作日的结束，他正走在外面，每个人都邀请他去酒吧，来吧迈克尔，我们想和你多待一会儿，是的，但他不能，是的，简来接他了，她从车里出来，她说你来开车，我喝了太多酒，太好了，很高兴你开车来这里，是的，我也这么想，然后迈克尔说瑜伽怎么样，她说我没去。他说，为什么？她说，我就是没去。噢。噢。太悲伤了。简的螺旋式下降，伙计。她要把迈克尔也一起拖下水。是的。然后维克拉姆告诉迈克尔，听着，伙计，如果你再努力一点，你也许能拿到那个奖金。维克拉姆在最后给了他一点鼓励。他说，只要照着剧本做就行。是的。是的。噢，迈克尔。好吧，我喜欢这一集。
episode. I love breaking down this first part. I can't wait to get to the next part. And thank you so much everyone for sending in your questions. And I, we just, Jen and I just freaking love doing this. We just love it. We love it. All right. Well, we will see you next week for Money Part 2. Money Part 2. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
我喜欢拆解这第一部分。我迫不及待想进入下一部分。非常感谢大家寄来的问题。我和珍娜真的非常喜欢做这件事。我们就是喜欢。我们喜欢。好吧。好吧，我们下周见，钱（第二部分）。钱（第二部分）。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。办公室女士是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·尤金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。办公室女士由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。
Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。